great hello my friends we are back it is
Friday February the
9th the
year
2024 wow and guys we are oh God I saw
this who posted this so funny a slam on
Gary ve they says God where did I see
that he's like I was following Gary ve
on Instagram and he had a post that says
we're already
12% through 2024 what have you've done
with it different perspec and they said
and then I thought to myself oh [__] I
need to unfollow Gary ve why am I still
following him you saw that you saw that
on Jeff FM's latest episode oh that was
Jeff that was Jeff of the show really
good joke okay thank you for for jogging
my memory different perspectives that's
funny we're we're you know I
have I've long been a Gary ve detractor
so I'm glad to see the world is catching
up our Bachelor is also funny he oh yeah
Jeff's hilarious
okay pointing it out yeah by the way
speaking of uh our Bach oh thank you to
Shopify for sponsoring our today we got
enough SP we love
them uh speaking of Jeff The Bachelor
applications once again a reminder to
all are
open we will be doing our first well I
guess there's an
official deadline here I know next
Wednesday we're going to begin the
series man it is Wednesday
but Sam and Ian aren't here and they
they're the um the
officiator of the rules here so I don't
know when's the deadline but I'm
assuming it's probably coming
up you know what I'm saying very lonely
back
here the dead sorry about that uh Z yeah
that must suck dude the deadline is
February 12th
February 12th you have three days yep yo
get that in tell all the tell all your
friends tell all your
aunties your yeah your friends he
specifically expressed interest in like
athletic Olympians Olympians you know
any Olympians oh Elite athletes only
gold medalist by the way we don't [__]
with we don't reproduce with bronze
silver bronze yeah no no so that's going
on we have honestly and I I know you
guys roll your eyes when I say this but
I'm being dead ass as they say kid say
that I
know no way way dude Teddy's taught me
how to dab for real oh my God it's like
this I think I do it right like that
right cuz I before I would do like this
and I didn't understand why it looks so
weird you're not doing it right it's
correcting I don't know how he picked it
up so fast he watched some dorks on
YouTube dud it a few times and then he's
like the dabbing Pro he does it crazy
good like he puts the hand back wow it's
just it looks like this kid's been
dabbing his whole life he does like a
dab dance a dab
walk the thing
is because he's only four it's funny
yeah he's only he if he was 15 then I'd
be having a conversation about the
dabbing with him yeah but because he's
four it's hilarious and we love it and
then Bruce the other day told Ethan
Roblox oh yeah Bruce knows who Mr Beast
is he's 2 years old I expect him to turn
two cultured he was saying Mr Beast
frankly before his second
birthday is it his favorite YouTuber
they both like him a lot I do like him
my favorite YouTuber I don't want say
favorite I think um Bruce is in a blippy
phase kind of right now mag Maggie all
those good ones yeah there's no embargo
on blippy in in your house I'm Pro
blippy no cuz the content good okay
compared to the other [__] on YouTube
blippy is like I mean if you just got to
let go of the diarrhea stuff I mean only
we know the kids don't know yeah they
don't know about that they don't know
what we know is that going to be when
they're older I'll be like uh hey you
guys remember that dude B we have to
tell you
something like finding out say that's
not real I love to show parents that
video I showed my brother-in-law he's
like what the [__] I'm like unal it's
like
dude it's crazy but his kid content is
really good
yeah I mean again compared to what else
is on YouTube kids very good it's
educational imagine finding out Mr
Rogers like [__] in someone's face or
something and filmed it as part of like
yeah no it'd be shot I mean I don't know
that I'd be able to take a ride down
that trolley
again you know yep I don't want to be
his neighbor after seeing
that he needs to let his neighbors know
that he's in the neighborhood you
exactly you know he's part of the
registry we got to let him all know but
Mr Rogers we love him and rest in peace
and also you can't defame the
dead right so he did that [__] he did it
if we have parents watching try Steven
Maggie because I think he's not as
famous but it's really good Stephen
Maggie is probably my favorite YouTube
content for kids it's so fun and
wholesome and creative I I love him yeah
me too yeah but anyway enough of that
shout out
the
so we
are um we have so much to to talk about
today and I truly mean it I mean look at
I'll give you guys a
taste we have okay name James Charles
put out a new song that's super
funny there's mad bivo updates
apparently he he's going to fight
someone and then also his girlfriend is
going to fight the girl he cheated on in
a boxing Mouse Grudge Match
Jesus it's it's the trashiest thing I've
ever seen in my life and I'm here for
it then we got the Taylor Swift Selen
Dion drama to uh to analyze frankly I
learned about this yesterday the the
team was showing me and I was captivated
by it I don't know about it apparently
Taylor Swift she caught a lot of flak
for her participation in the Grammys one
part was for snubbing Selene Dion who is
a stiff
person she that's the name of it she she
suffers from stiff person syndrome yes
the disase you're going to have to catch
me up on this whole thing it's tough
It's a lot you guys know
I we love Seline obviously the disase
has a silly name and I mean that with
peace and love yeah it has to do person
disease she's a stiff person yeah I mean
by definition that would be correct
so I invented a new slur about her
yesterday but I won't should I say
it I invented a new slur against maybe
let's wait until we get to the that's a
crazy crazy statement
bro it's actually well it's not every
day you get to invent a new slur no it's
Friday [__] it yeah I called her and I
didn't even me I'll be I meant this with
peace and love all of the peace and love
in the world I called her a
stiffy that's why I said the debate
should be the swifties versus the
stickies
and I mean we say that with all the love
and respect for stiff people
everywhere absolutely I had a I had an
idea I don't know if occurred to them
have they tried
chiropracty it's
still wow I heard they're good at
making they're good at uh a little stiff
there
right I mean it's kind of funny cuz a
chiropractor would do that and obviously
this is a serious condition but like
your ass would lay on the table and they
just like [__] start Cy chopping you
right it's still ducky you want this I
got a trueu for
you it's
still anyway I mean I you know no
offense to the uh the like you said AB
the swifties versus the stiffies yeah
and that was AB said that not me right
I've was seen a lot more and you're a
fan I am a fan of both of them that's
why this is so hard on me slon is your
favorite album ever I do know that about
you my favorite album yeah is isn't she
my favorite concert was oh w w w w I
hate going to concerts but I was loving
that [__] right funny um you but you
like selon more than Theon W that really
beautiful you really like Selene more
than Swift though right I've never heard
you talk about Swift no I like Taylor
Swift um just different Man Taylor Swift
was like I like her because my nieces
like listening to Taylor Swift buta
right and Lena yeah Lena as well but
Selen Deion I grew up with that's not
Lena that's Lena that's oh yeah Lena's a
uh she's a swifter
[Music]
mhm uh so we have all that to analyze
also she there was another weird uh
wrinkle people got mad because she
brought up her friend Lana Del re on
stage who was nominated for best album
and did not win so Taylor brought her on
stage I don't think she was nominated
for best album she was nominated for
another award well then who gives a [__]
no she she was it was best album as well
I yeah dive into those yeah we're
because it sounds to me like um Taylor
didn't do anything I have to Taylor's
inating
her well this is just based on what you
said so far well hold on don't be so
stiff about your opinion but stay
flexible that's [__] funny that's
very [__] funny was funny I didn't
say
anything
I didn't say anything at all um oh this
is my favorite story it's not in the
title but God I love it so Vos I know a
lot of there's probably some crossover
he's a political streamer
socialist And he as many people before
him on the internet accidentally opened
their is there a nicer way to say like I
don't like saying the p word not like P
not like CP just to be clear like porn
like is there an a euphemism for that
corn
cornn which I kind of don't it's not
fair to corn to like you ruin corn for
everybody porography it was a spicy
folder spicy
folder why can't you just say it why
can't I don't know DIY word paranoid
about YouTube yeah it's an it's it's a v
over here making up new slurs and he's
worried about same yeah but they don't
the AI doesn't know yet about the Stiers
sers the AI CAU up BR the a dude I'm
like [__] I'm years ahead of the
AI you know Tucker Carlson could say it
for you if you prefer that what say what
Tucker Carlson can say it for you if you
prefer that stiffy oh no the you have a
sound I'm assuming okay go ahead Carl
exploding Milk
porn so Vos like many before
him uh have accidentally opened their
spicy folder
M which as a concept is something that
I'm truly have always found bizarre I
mean no offense all you guys who have a
collection of of spicy folders but the
idea of just is a good question bringing
it all together and it it looked like it
all together his was a pretty serious uh
organizational operation really yes but
any but anyway the categories have
categories they wear like subfolders in
the folder the folder was literally
called to be
sorted yeah let me know because I
[__] files on top of files files on
top of files I didn't know that but it's
not that he was looking at corn it's
that what was in the folder was
something I hadn't I hadn't seen happen
to a Creator before it was actually corn
of
horses horse [__] just the right height
no bucket is required drawn ones right I
don't know how much of a difference that
makes but it was horse con was it actual
horse con I think it different dra of
horse it was drawing okay so drawing
phys no real images of horse no real
animals were involved yeah I mean that's
good okay we appreciate that but there's
also other weird [__] in there I'll be
honest like uh there was some what's
referred to as loli show us it's like a
genre of hentai where the girls are very
young that that was mixed with the with
the horse horses yeah how do those two
go together it does I don't know
why the horses were it's just degeneracy
all around
degeneracy I think we have to start with
a poll of finding out how many people
actually have a folder for their spicy
spicy corn I have a few friends that had
a folder because I've only heard about
it in like criminal
cases no me too it's a DAT line thing
yeah but your friends e how long ago was
that it was a long [__] time ago yeah
that's different different when you
don't have like the internet on your
phone at all day yeah it's true I mean
yeah but should we do a poll we sure can
do a poll the poll's up it's already up
I'm curious that's like lime wire stuff
but anyway there's a lot of vosch fans
screaming at their screen right now that
a lot of the stuff that he's been
lambasted for in the past has been taken
out of context so what we've prepared
here today in the interest of
fairness uh and and in the pursuit of
justice and Truth we have brought the
full Clips with all the context we are
going to revisit some of the best hits
for example you some of this stuff is
going to blow your guys' asses out that
they have not seen this before it's
truly I don't know how we survived some
of this stuff and as a as a as a Creator
I actually don't I like a fair bit of
his content okay so I'm I you might
consider me somewhat of a fan of his I
definitely would watch his videos from
time to time okay and he struck me as an
eloquent smart
guy however are you did it did it affect
you in the way you look at him now can
you can you still watch his conent no
absolutely not I mean I don't think so I
guess I'll see how I feel but uh I feel
that we as a society we need we need to
put our the line somewhere we can't be
tolerant up to [__]
horses like we have to put our foot down
tolerance has a limit you guys [__] and
I come to you as a lib I am a Mr
tolerance I tolerate everybody and
everything mhm but we have to put our
foot down when has tolerance gone too
far I dare to uh say it's when you're
dking off the horse
[__]
and and I do and you know again the
poll what's the 14% said yes that's
basically nothing that's basically Only
You serial killers and and no wait a
minute 14% that's quite High that's not
low guys there's 8,000 votes what's 14%
of 8,000 the history of Po exactly Dan
you're being obus this is very it's 14
for sure extreme yeah but I'm just
pointing out there are still it's almost
90% said no there are hundreds and
hundreds of people in this audience
right now that have a porn I think the
poll sorry Dan is a little flawed not
your fault listen this is the reason we
didn't clarify if that includes their
own content like stuff they that's they
have I feel like you think there's that
many of people in our
a just saying like your own news from
your significant other phot of your own
nudes no see I never done that I didn't
about that to be honest I'm old but I've
never taken a photo of myself naked and
nor would I don't think anyone dude if
I'm trying to turn someone on I'm not
sending them a picture me we we need a
sub poll of finding out if anybody even
thought of that when they said yes I
don't think that to be a significant uh
I don't think that would be
a a uh statistically why are people
saying Dan has a folder what
no I I was pointing out that it was
still astounding how many people had it
not that I was like look there's a
there's a great man I don't believe and
and by the way I'm not above admitting
that I I do watch corn from not from
time to time you watch corn yeah yeah
you know that oh ducky yeah I'm joking
yeah I know you
are I mean we've you know what and um
and and that's fine I think that that's
fine however there's a certain barrier
that you
break that is starts when you have a
folder called to be
sorted with with um with folders and
folders and folders but I'm not I'm not
judging people you know uh because
listen some people are born with
uh he's not harming anyone I mean right
like that's that's important to to I
guess remain all right there's a
clarifying pole going up do you have a
porn folder that isn't your own this is
more confusing well I think it's isn't
your own wait AB is saying that um
people people are saying I'm right so
the percent oh [__] it is changed
percentage is even more ex I don't
consider pictures of yourself or your
sign of other to be porn right that's
yeah well they're just taking I I see
where the confusion came in okay so AB
you stands corrected 11% has shifted too
only
11% I'll also say this that definitely
strikes me as a guy thing and we have a
large female
audience that's a dude thing for sure
having a folder
yeah but uh again I've been wrong about
wom say Dan definitely has a por folder
I'm sorry I'm trying to be diplomatic
y'all are [__] weird if you have one
of those folders I'm sorry I'm try I'm
just trying to be diplomatic okay trying
to call me out my thing about the folder
is this you there's no need for the
folder in this day and age like right
exactly unless I don't even I don't
download music that is extra right
exactly I don't even download like it it
means that you found like it means a lot
to you you found something exactly right
this is so rare I had so much trouble
finding this which by the way if it's
hard to find on the internet it's
probably [__] up probably illegal yeah
maybe illegal yeah right so there's just
so you know if you have a folder it
doesn't mean you're a bad person but all
bad people have
folders yes
that's what
I Vos is talking about uh me on his on
his thing apparently oh whatever um yeah
I'm not going to go to a stream I'm not
going to make that
mistake I'm going to keep it contained
right here and vosch if you're watching
we are going to give you a fair shake a
fair Shake of the horse's
[__] we're going to watch everything in
full context that that's two for two man
that's thanks bro killing it today
so um yeah I mean one one of the things
he says which I guess requires context
is quote I am yet to hear a convincing
moral or legal argument as to why
c-word p word CP should be
illegal what yes he said it on camera
it's filmed show us it's a crazy thing
so we'll get into all that I'm very
excited uh I mean it's obviously it's
you know I'm excited we're not getting
into it right now I guess we should
we've already but I was just I wanted to
spice it up cuz we also have
um uh a really fun cavcav update as well
dude we have this crazy ccav update we
found a user on the subred it was
pointed out by other
users and I saw it and I sent a red
alert in the chat we have to Archive
this
immediately and it's somebody who's been
posting for a year on the subreddit
almost entirely on reads about Brad the
bull with intimate knowledge of their
relationship that has not yet been
publicly shared I'm obsessed I love it
it is
truly wow captivating
mhm and this [__] guy I was listening
to the last episode and I just couldn't
believe how entertaining it was mhm I'm
happy to hear that you know cuz
something I'm really passionate about
when you guys said you were going to
watch it the next episode I was like m
wonder if this is going to get old no
but I was like laughing the whole time
Wikipedia is like not real so I mean
we'll keep going as long as people enjoy
it I'm I'm definitely looking forward to
episode three where he actually is going
to um bring his old friend Bill Cosby
over for from Jello and Old Times old
time stories all the most popular the
coolest the bad boy getting a lot of
fights you know but you you have a great
time you love to party and you you're so
popular bro you you are like
50 in
2005 he's talking like the like the
younger
brother my brother's so cool he parties
has fun anyway let's talk about the Vos
thing because we're already here
okay oh there's other stuff I want to
talk about at the top though no tease it
out let's get let's Circle back to that
we'll Circle back we'll Circle
back okay so here's something I wanted
to address at the top here is um for
those who are aware
there's been a Teddy fresh
drama um it's been a scandalous week let
me see the post so last week we started
a new exactly last
Friday a new dropping schedule whereby
we instead of doing it like once or
sometimes twice per month mhm we said
let's start doing it through throughout
the month basically daily mhm and our
and our our theory behind that was
because when we drop so much stuff at
once we feel like a lot of the really
cool great
pieces often times fall through the
cracks yeah I thought it could be fun to
like give each piece its own moment and
in a way also Force us to have to talk
about each piece and show it on socials
and and the whole thing each piece it's
due a lot of times we just don't we
don't feature all the pieces and and
we'll post like photos and then we feel
like well engagement is going down or
something and we'll just kind of like
stop posting from their release and so a
lot of stuff that came out won't get
really featured like now some people I
don't I mean listen so the people were
upset and the reason for that being
that they would have to spend a lot more
on shipping mhm which makes sense I
understand understand that you know and
um and I we we all understand that and
and we understand that the shopping
experience for you for you guys is
better the way it
was there is some feedback that kind of
um perplexed me a lot of people were
saying we were doing it to make money
and that we were scamming yeah I saw
somebody call it a cash grab which
shipping didn't make any sense who who's
Cas unless I'm in bed with
FedEx I don't own any FedEx stock for
the record I'm just love stamps.com I
was about to say where are stamps.com
out yeah they kicked me back on that one
no yeah the shipping fees are just
covering shipping it's you know but you
guys are right in that shipping has
gotten so
expensive clothing has gotten so
expensive so we
underestimated the financial strain that
would impose on already
expensive uh product to participate in
and so we rolled it back and and to make
matters to try to make things as a
gesture of uh our love and appreciation
to all you guys we have decided to offer
free shipping on all us domestic orders
from now until the end of the month free
shipping yo free shipping on every
damn yeah damn that's you don't see that
anymore and you know why cuz it costs a
[__] forun like actually it's crazy
um people were begging us not to do this
Jeff Bezos does it yeah well you pay you
pay a subscription fee for that right
good point they get like a trillion
dollars a
year and also it is kind of insane that
they do that yeah so yeah they I mean
yeah they ate cost basic they were like
not profitable for the first 20 years
they do it to run everybody else out of
business yeah right so people were beg
our our accountant was like begging us
they says you cannot do free shipping
they they say you cannot do this please
and then there was people inside we also
said anyone who's
bought this month you can reach out to
our support team and we'll refund you
the cost of shipping that you already
paid oh the owners have lost their mind
dude we had people on the inside saying
you cannot do this this is insane it's
literally the Comm you're killing me
Larry commercial accountant is yelling
at youe Ethan you're killing me
a so like it's it's not a cash grab I
don't understand even that leap of logic
it takes to get there it's just shipping
and um we are going to
basically listen it was an
experiment and it was we got we got it
we got the feedback listen in business
you try things we've been doing Teddy
fresh for like six seven years now and
we've been doing the monthly drops which
which we love doing I think it's a great
we're going to go back to that and
sometimes it will be twice per month and
sometimes once per month just like how
it used to seemed like a good idea at
the time I thought it would be fun but
yeah seemed like a good idea obviously
it's it's more complicated well people
were very passionately against this and
you know I and I appreciate that they
care that much they do I do too it's
nice that they do I mean that's one
thing that I always really appreciate
about our customers they're very loyal
and they care and so it's important for
me to to make it a two-way relationship
show them that we care
too absolutely absolutely so I mean we
are going to spend a fortune we're not
going to make a lot of money this month
probably if any but that doesn't matter
to us which is why I said it and also I
was getting annoyed that all the
comments were about shipping when this
collection is so fire right that's annoy
I love this February collection and so I
just want to get back to talking about
how cool everything is Che this out dude
check this new [__] bike
Jersey oh yeah the teddy fresh
sport oh yeah I had um a cool dude who
asked for that my DM a cool dude cool
dude he's someone we seed to he's so
cool and El rocking the uh overalls yes
okay you guys have to see Lena cuz uh
I'm raising about this this set here
nice oh the whole thing is Teddy frh
yes there it is look so cute
to add some stuff to the folder later
and check
out I heard that
one yeah you own in on that didn't you
that's funny check out Dan real quick
because Dan is this is this out yet I
wasn't sure it will be so so on Monday
everything will come out Monday all
February will come out yeah and they'll
be free shipping on all orders all
orders ERS to the end of the month you
heard that right who does who else does
Dom domestic because honestly if we
shipped like uh International it would
we would lose a fantastic amount of
money like we would we would just be
losing money straight up who want to
lose some money today but you know
like the the rationale we had behind
creating the Classics Collection was
like everything's getting more expensive
and everyone's raising their price
everyone's charging a ton for
shipping and we wanted to go the
opposite direction and um let's say [__]
it let's lower our
prices and the hope is of course that
they Zed you zagged exactly you know the
the play is hopefully that through
volume because people like that that you
make up and it and it was successful I'm
really happy with how
it came out so I I like I like that we
have both options where we can have the
classics but also still have our uh what
we call inline collection and still go
full on with all the details and and
charge more
so we definitely went the wrong way on
this one we we created a process that
made the cost more expensive so I hope
you guys like um the free shipping I
hope that lowers the bar of entry for a
lot of people that wanted to try the
thing you know our free shipping has
been 150 traditionally because again
it's like it's just
a a cost value uh analysis but I do
think about um this whole thing has kind
of been a catalyst for thinking about
things differently for me where I'm
wondering if we should lower our
shipping
bar going forward right maybe we're
going to have to talk about it like
throughout the month yeah I'll have to
see how it goes throughout the month but
um let the conversation begin free
shipping is definitely very stream well
I was like can we do free shipping like
all the time I don't know that we can
Dude our accountant was like she was
pulling her hair out it's a lot of money
she saids we're going to be at of
business I says well that's what it
takes Lena also has the uh Lena should
show how you have the jacket she has the
modular jacket but she's not she has the
bottom disconnected from it yeah that's
fire Lena let's do
nice oh
that's how I want to wear it Bo boom
boom boom what's up boom
boom that is all online so you get a cro
jacket if you want or
not
Sayo all right so Monday at 10:00
a.m. um tune in because everything will
be out and there's so many cool stuff
this month I'm not
kidding good fun so that's it you know
but I do Wonder like d what if we just
said [__] it and we like cut our margins
to like almost nothing and said free
shipping for everyone I wonder if that
would I wonder what that would do if it
would be worth it or there wouldn't be
that much more people participating in
which it's uh going to cut too much into
the profit in my opinion what do you
what do you think about I think you
should pay people to take the clothes I
was going to say send it for free oh
[__] earthquake earthquake holy [__]
we've never never exp wow
that y that was our first Earth awesome
Lena's [__] in bricks over here guys
everybody everybody just stay where you
are stay where you are okay that was a
very minor one yeah that was a small one
the big one big one that is the biggest
one I've ever felt really yes it was
pretty shocking me too that was awesome
that was like a movie I dove under the
table that's what they teach you in
school to do that was good that's okay
you did the right thing you did the
right thing I was you're trained going
to tell people to do that if it got
worse but that was the advice that they
give now is just to stay where you are
until the shaking stops it used to be
run into the doorway get under the desk
and stuff but they found that more
people were getting injured trying to
get to get there that said we are at
desks it would probably be advisable to
get under there yeah I think but I hear
what you're saying I mean there's was
that your first yeah very first I've
never ever felt anything that's pretty
no my first your no my first was when I
first moved here oh yeah yeah I remember
there was one like right after he moved
I was on a skateboard too it was sick
was a weird feeling so there'll probably
be
aftershocks or it happens sometimes
there'll be a bigger one there's a
pre-shock could be a for shock how
however do you think it was a sign from
God about Teddy fresh dude he was he
free it was saying don't do the free
shipping you're crazy maybe he was
saying good free shipping do free
shipping initial report is 4.7 in,
Oaks oh [__] that's pretty significant
uh 4.7 that's a decent Shaker that's a
decent Shaker for sure real quick I'm
checking my my cameras at home we
haven't mounted our new TV so and
Thousand Oaks is pretty close although
they must have felt it a lot stronger
yeah I'm worried about my [__] Legos
dude ho oh
no I got to take
SE again the good thing about the
architecture in California it's all made
to withstand earthquakes why
everything's made of wood and uh the all
the skyscrapers are are made with
earthquakes good earthquake code here
they're on rollers the tall buildings is
that nuts yeah dude I'm it's crazy that
a building I felt like got I got yed
like a good this bit to just one side
like I mean that how the
[__] such a weird experience I that was
so weird I hope that you guys
don't the the when they're big it's
terrifying
like it's you get thrashed yeah I felt
like my share just go you're like an ant
being juggled around in a cuz you just
are so helpless and so small power of
the Earth's asking if we're all okay a
you guys went through the '94 yeah yeah
that was terrifying yeah yeah that's
that was uh Che okay yeah that was the
one that the big one of my life the
Earth uh I've heard about that from you
a lot the 94 uh North North Ridge quake
and I was in Ventura that [__] was crazy
it was in the middle of the night was I
was in the West Valley our house got
[__] up oh so you were right there our
house got red tagged we had to move out
oh yeah the the cracked the foundation
of the house W yeah they were going
around red tagging houses and buildings
that were affected they were damaged to
the point of not being safe wow yeah
they would come around and you'd either
get green or yellow or red depending on
like how safe the building was and ours
got Reds so we we moved out for like a
year well wow my parents had insurance
so they got the foundation fixed damn
that's nuts that's crazy dude the
earthquake insurers must [__] hate
that they're like the whole city now we
got to pay pay up for to keep the earth
clean and do what even yeah well
earthquake earthquake insurance is
pretty expensive here uh to be honest I
wonder why yeah but I hope I hope that
uh you guys don't feel a bigger one cuz
that shit's crazy but there you go you
got you got a little intro in
Jesus nothing nothing to worry about
though people people people don't get
hurt you know here in in LA because
we're we're fortunate to have good
infrastructure and everything's um built
a lot of the times you have earthquakes
that are about that size or maybe a
little
bigger in like uh developing countries
like what happened in Haiti and because
of the or recently in Turkey in Turkey
right because of the infrastructure
there and a lot of the stuff isn't built
built with earthquakes in mind I didn't
even know they had earthquakes in Turkey
but I know in the Middle East
everything's made of stone which
obviously is not flexible yeah when I
moved there I was like why is everything
made of wood right that's that's exactly
why and so um yeah people don't really
get hurt unless there's like an
unprecedented like 9.0 and then the
Earth opens up and then a and probably a
lot of people would die in that case
well there were there were a decent
amount of deaths in the Northridge
Earthquake that we were talking about
earlier but it was all people it was not
all but most of them were people that
lived in the specific type of apartment
building that was very specific to La
called a dingbat apartment you know
about this m no if you there's this type
of apartment you'll you still see them
all the time they've now all been
reinforced because of the Northridge
Earthquake it was a very like typical
Southern California style apartment
building that had the building over the
garage the garage was like on the ground
level and then all of the units are on
stilts above it oh I hate that [__]
bunch of those collaps bro I see those
all the time in the hills and I'm like
yeah you could not pay me to live in
that [__] house yep I saw one
recently when we were driving God it's
like the house doesn't touch Solid
Ground yeah it's just this like tin like
super thin hor yeah my aunt used to live
in one Glendale um and I was always
scared to go in that house because of
that
yeah yeah but um very good anyway we Dan
was saying we should give it out for
free and God said
no you want to try that again Dan and we
see if their earthquake happen I was
actually saying I'm scared now go ahead
this is the real test of faith I was
saying that you guys should pay the
customers to take the teddy fresh off
your hands I'm the one that said free
Dan said Pay that's a really those are
really a progressive yeah I mean that's
a hell of a way to move product like you
said you got to do what you got to
do what about trying it for a small
amount of time and see how it works what
giving it away for free no no no the
free the free shipping well we are doing
that this month this month we'll see
like how bad is it but but yeah I mean
we were thinking like oh what if we go
down to 50 which is a lot
better but then I'm like well at that
point let's just go for it let's just
[__] go for it
Larry like me
50 but we'll see we'll see but anyway
thank you for your guys support and
shout out to this
one it's nice to see a lot of people
being appreciative and and uh
understanding there's been one comment
that made me laugh though that I had to
pull up it's [__] nice out where is
it let me
see uh um AB has it you talking about
the one that was sent earlier yeah one
see oh see here this this was at the top
of ela's
page and this can't be like a real
criticism but the thing is it has a lot
of likes 40 87
likes so you tell me what you think of
this they says everyone's praising them
for listening to their customers and
being awesome but like they did the new
drop in the first place knowing people
would be paying extra shipping that was
probably a big reason they chose to do
it to make more money but they didn't
expect so much push back a true Queen
would have realized that before making
the mistake they are playing dumb sorry
I didn't think about everything
I that that's not good faith criticism
you're not a true Queen well I mean you
don't make money off the shipping we
don't but also it's like that kind of
undercuts that shipping is a real cost
that we have no we have no effect on
what shipping costs they go clothing
company and and buy something and see I
mean it's expensive as [__] yeah that
being said I do love this uh philosophy
in life where it's like if somebody did
something
wrong no matter the minor or severity of
it they're [__] dead to me forever
they should have not made a mistake to
begin with and shame on them I'm per
I've never made a mistake and I expect
everybody to treat me like a perfect
legend that I am this would be great
conversation when we go on the failure
podcast
oh good point good point cuz I was
thinking about talking about when I
wasn't popular in school
yeah as my big failure in life but um
this is this one's probably better well
you could go to Brad the B thing it's
like yeah no it was really hard um
making our making our clothing line at
first it wasn't working we were losing
money oh but but oh no but it's it's
worked out fantastically in the end yeah
oops sorry D yeah in no way what I call
it a failure no no no it was a huge
success but anyway shout out to this
person who with the the constructive
feedback sh
out shout out kind of the bad boy
getting a lot of fights you know but you
you have a great time you love to party
and you you're so popular oh my
god get enough should we get into that
no we should do our sponsor and then
we all kinds of we have so much fun
stuff so let's do let's thank Shopify
speaking of Teddy fresh guess where
Teddy fresh is hosted Shopify baby the
best e-commerce platform the world has
ever seen
that's right down they are there for you
from the
beginning all the way to billion doll
inter uh InterContinental Mega
operations and take for example what we
did in the last week we decided to
change our release schedule Shopify
makes it super easy you can schedule one
product to release you can schedule a
whole collection mhm ahead of time and
then how easy was it to change it back
like this you see and and making the
shipping free one click the the decision
to do it priceless oh I don't know yeah
decision to do it
dumb no but but for real we started our
business on Shopify from the first day
and that was one of the best decisions
we ever made in terms of making our
business because their platform is so
easy to use neither of us knew the first
thing about graph uh programming and we
were able to make a a nice
operating uh e-commerce website from
basically nothing it's never been down
it's we've never had any security or
downtime issues we've never had any
issues support is
fantastic they've got tons of add-ons by
huge reputable serious people uh that
you can add on to your shop great
customer support um it it really has
everything you need from from the
beginning all the way to to all the way
to the top baby
um they also have stuff like you can get
a in-person POS system so if you're
selling if you want to sell your stuff
like at a swap meet or at a PO popup
whatever you you bring one of their POS
systems you could charge people's cards
in person and it will get deducted from
the inventory it's phenomenal they've
got it all really they really
do can't recommend it enough Shopify
helps you turn uh browsers into buyers
with internet's best converting checkout
36% better on average than other leading
Commerce
losers I do love their checkout yeah
whenever I get that option as the
Shopper I always pick that one yeah yeah
um so anyway well I I encourage
everybody who's interested in in getting
into business for themselves to uh
consider trying Shopify you will not
regret it that's my my promise my my
pledge to you so sign up for a $1 per
month trial period at shopify.com after
dark or lowercase one more time go to
shopify.com
afterdark now to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
after
dark thank you thank
you well
done well
done what an ad read wow Heidi
says uh I just got a confirmation from a
blood test that I am super pregnant
finally shout out to all H Mom
congratulations can't wait to join the
team family let's
go congratulations this is like baby
season I know so many people that are
pregnant right now congratulations
congratulations Ma I need the max wi I
need the max
baby I need the max
triplets I don't know congratul
you want to know something crazy Ela
started putting her to go bag together
yes that's some [__] wow because last
time I was like yeah I have a bag half
ready and I was like last minute We'll
add whatever we need and there was no
time to do that last time so this time
I'm going to have it ready and
packed to the last thing like a phone
charger is going to be in there I'm not
going to do it last minute nice amazing
everything well because we well we
learned from last time that we don't we
don't have a lot of time to daily dally
yeah I'm scared I don't know how fast it
will it might not be fast but if it is
fast it will be it'll be as fast because
in my opinion based on the last time
because I don't think it generally takes
longer it's always faster than the last
time there's no rules it could be and
okay and generally generally yeah yeah
um yeah I mean the the nurses when we
call we're like hey the the water broke
what should we do they're like take your
time get something to eat shower eat
something and then come and we're like
okay and that was bad advice really
wasn't good advice in our situation I
never did as she almost gave birth in
the toilet as I was parking the
car yeah I was just thinking about that
today crazy I was in the toilet like
because I felt like I needed to poop
which now I also know that's like part
of the pushing for a baby to come out
yeah um and so I was like I'm just going
to try that even though I was in pain
like fully crazy pain cont oh God that's
nuts and I was like I'm just going to
try that really quick that must that and
I could have I could barely even like
sit there and then I felt like oh wow
I'm pushing like a baby not poop holy
[__] and then I I had to scream help
like I've never done that the this
nobody nobody's taking you seriously cuz
ELO was like in like serious
contractions and compared to the first
time I knew it was serious that she was
about to give birth and I kept telling
everyone like yo you have to you have to
take this seriously she's going she's
going into labor and everyone's like
okay whatever you know come with us this
way get comfortable I was just thinking
this morning about that moment of like
shouting help in the bathroom thank God
somebody heard you you're not good at
projecting let's be real and then what
you're not you're not a good sh I'm
telling you it was it's a weird feeling
I never had to shout help yeah it's a
weird thing um and then I saw my doctor
which was so cool cuz the the one that
was like seeing me the whole time he
happened to be there and he was the one
that ended up delivering Brucey but
don't let this discourage you um what
was your name because it was actually a
really good experience it was fast it
was fast and I actually don't remember
the pain don't remember it Heidi so I
wish for you Heidi giving birth in the
toilet almost I remember the whole time
saying I can't do this and the doctor
was like he's coming out and I was like
I can't do it I can't do it and then he
was out wow so were you even pushing or
was it just I one time it was like just
do one push it's almost holy
[__] crazy it was so crazy we'll be fast
this time though is the point we're
going we're going no I'm I saying we're
going we will be so fast yeah we're
going
yes although we need to have like what
if it's in the middle of the night and
then someone needs to come be with the
kids like we can't leave them there God
right last time my mom was there like
what the what do you
do bring them I what else would you God
now you added a whole new level of quest
that I I guess we'd have to bring them
yeah and then just call my parents to
come get them oh my God now well we'll
be on high alert when we're near your D
day don't know what to do we had bring
them bringing them takes too long here's
what we'll do here's what we'll do
when we're near your due date we'll tell
my parents be ready we're going to call
you and then you guys got to come
straight away to the house
yeah now I'm I'm I'm going to be so
stressed now about this have a backup as
well because that's what happened with
my aunt Uncle my parents were supposed
to watch the kids they didn't answer the
phone exactly they're not going to
answer the phone they're going to be
sleeping well they better damn answer
the phone okay we got to think about it
tonight well we could call my brother
we'll think about it tonight he's
closer no he's not just give me a call
he's as give me a call
call call I would call you guys I don't
want to put I'll probably I'll probably
be outside any we could call yeah be
there anyway call Lena AB show up
protect I will say this Dan you're
invited I will say this if you want Lena
text me she never has her phone on her I
I'm always up that's actually a good
that's a good option is going to be our
plan we got you I think that's the best
of somebody showing up true AB will show
up and you're up at weird hours right
yeah yeah okay there you go done easy
let's go you guys don't understand
living the house with kids takes so long
it's a process it's a process I got you
and doing that especially in the middle
of the night they're going to be like
what is happening I'm tired I'm
cranky very good thank you
okay let's get where do we where do you
guys want to start we have so many great
things uh we should talk about that c
Cav update before we get too much deeper
it's quick okay so um I had a DUI in
2005 yeah I know I know um because we
had so much fun watching failure episode
2 we actually well Cameron made a um an
homage to all of our favorite Great
Moments and I hope that you guys enjoy
in case you don't want to sit through
the whole thing this kind of sums up the
whole journey very good very good here
it is today we are very
fortunate go ahead go ahead Ryan to have
two amazing people Bryce Hall who's uh
one of the world's most famous people if
not the most famous and fail my marriage
Brad the Bull Basin can you tell us
um um you know kind of yay like oh
you're you're stupid you're unpopular
you have no friends like H that's why
nobody likes you like those types of
things you know Fair
Point a lot of high school kids
hopefully are going to be watching this
oh my God you know hot girls and
pathetic scum
um oh my god
dude Brad was like the most popular kid
in high school yeah you you really
shouldn't shouldn't talk
you're fat you're you're really fat like
you're not who you used to be and you're
not looking that great so some say Daddy
no no no one says daddy daddy's not a
thing that's crazy uh no I'm joking what
[Laughter]
um you're fat you're hairy like it's not
it's not a
thing like it's just you and the weight
so jeez he's giving him a hard time
about the weight 2001 with the 911
happening you did it it was epic and it
felt really really amazing is that why
they call you the bull cuz you never
give up kind of run through it he like I
don't know that's why they call him Brad
the bull you see he blew up my bucked
up Logan Paul has R
issues I built what I'll still say today
is I think in Hollywood the most
prolific change that are Hollywood had
ever seen [__] I actually ask my dad
if I could
$50,000 you know kind
of one thing that was stopping
[Laughter]
me I wasn't the most popular kid in high
school
um yeah um I was just more interested in
smoking weed
like like tell me what that
is some people just you know get very
see I'm not going to be like this this
is not going to work I'm not this is not
the
conclusion um and you know just piece of
[__] I'm really glad you guys failed
your marriages had I not failed at my
marriage we wouldn't be here as brothers
best friends and [__] you like I'm
good [__] just got weird [__] you don't
call me again like 110 times you know I
I I just I don't accept it oh man that
was phenomenal cam wow Cam that was
great the goat that was amazing thank
you Sav me a lot of time having to watch
the whole thing yeah it made it
watchable at least oh my God that was
phenomenal now that's a
podcast wow so much of that works so
well it works so well do you need to say
anything even though it's obvious that
is a th% transformed content I mean give
me a break try to sue me for that one
dummy
give me a break dude you look like such
a
fool I got a run to the bathroom Okay
okay
so uh petition for cam to create an H3
YouTube poop Channel I remember those
you remember that sh YouTube poop of
course yeah I grew up on it it would be
a good membership perk possibly cam po
YouTube
poop
yeah bring back old Mario footage all
that uh 30 35th attempt to have my
membership Milestone notice hi Dan
that's from Nick yeah uh no it's from uh
Midwestern kayak adventur I almost
didn't recognize them oh yeah hello
Kayak
Adventure thank you for uh 35 months of
being a member wow took us that long
that's three years three it took us
three years to notice his Milestone
sh yeah so speaking of um the failure
crew we uh I mentioned briefly
about some users
uncovered
what some evidence may
suggest of course there's no definitive
way to know so I wouldn't say it's
either Brad or
Ryan's but I have reason to suspect that
it might be here's the post ladies and
gentlemen we got him so I oh wait this
is a different one sorry this is about
uh you guys aren't going to believe this
but apparently according to this user
he's getting fake reviews on his podcast
weird that's a big accusation do they
have some any kind of like suggestive
evidence to back that up he says I
Googled one of the five star review
names on fail your pod and found this
website listing reviews from table read
podcast H what's the table read podcast
let's take a
look
let's listen to the table read
episodes okay so these are so wait he's
saying these are the same reviews well
here let me read yeah not only did I
find it have the same reviewer it had
the same reviews grammatical errors
included left on failure nilia booya FBI
and mods Nila Bozo nilia boo example uh
provided Dr Saul durgen I look forward
to everyone every day which of course is
a
super human thing to say about for sure
spelling and missing space the same on
both of the podcast
reviews nandon 67 said I've recommended
this podcast to all my family and
friends both the same user and the same
reviewer according to this gentleman
here and Jonathan 5r I remember him he's
one of a he's one of the great reviewers
of our time Jonathan 5r yeah I do
remember that one one of the best
podcasts out there keep it up guys same
what are the chances I mean that's crazy
I mean there might be an overlapping
interest there with the uh whatever this
other podcast was and failure same
demographic perhaps but the same person
leaving The Identical review that seems
farfetch the odds must be astronomical
on that but there it is I and then not
only once but like five times that's got
to be like one in a gajillion I don't
think you can even calculate the odds on
that uh the top comment on this post is
it feels like every aspect of Ryan's
podcast was specifically created just to
get Ethan to react to it that's how I
feel that's what's so weird about this
whole thing we'll see
though I'm here for it all
man uh there's actually more uh that we
unveiled here or users
unveiled uh Ryan allegedly bought 2,000
likes on Brad the bull episode I don't
believe that why would he do that oh
there's even upate to that one under
that let me just do the updated one then
so here's the latest podcast with Brad
the and Bryce hall now I've been on
YouTube a while but I'm first to admit
that I don't know
everything about YouTube I know a lot
but can somebody explain to me how you
can have 5,000 views and 12,000 likes
these
balls wait and this isn't like I here's
the thing I know that that's possible
when you post a video and immediately
because the views don't update
immediately I was just thinking about
that however it doesn't stop at 5,000
views this has been out though like send
me the link now let's take a look vard
cuz like first day first couple hours
it's like 10,000 I don't remember it
will stop at some point but I don't know
that 5,000 do they even I think they
fixed that do that yeah I remember that
happening but I don't think that even
happens anymore yeah interesting yeah
it's that was definitely like a few
years ago I don't yeah yeah so here I
mean so this has been up two days yeah
and it has 17,000 likes what on 7 and a
half thousand views now that's I'm not a
mathematician I've never seen that
happen yeah it is a new one here's the
thing if I like it if I like it and I
say oh well I want to like it twice cuz
I'm a huge fan but then it unlikes it so
that would mean that that's not what's
happening right yeah it couldn't be
couldn't be I don't understand but some
there's some funny business here I can't
put my finger on it huh anyway I want I
do return my dislike not for any reason
just as a critical feedback to them
yeah we crazy seen I wish there was a
love
button yeah we have phone 177,000 I mean
even Jimmy Lee is slicker with his with
his social medas than that yeah yeah a
little more tacked bro that's over twice
as many views
can we ask somebody YouTube what is that
sure I I can ask my YouTube guy yeah let
me send him a message I've never
something like this yeah you send him a
message I'll send him this link and say
is it how does this happen I'm just
curious yeah or maybe can you drop the
link in the if there's a bug yeah yeah I
want to know if there's a bug or
something yeah but to be honest I don't
want this channel to get banned yeah
that's the thing I don't want this Chann
I want to say it but oh I don't want to
miss episode three yeah let's not mess
with anything
oh
you know what I mean yeah no we be
missing my boy Nigel lithco I'm leaving
for episode three 7.3 th000 uh likes on
on
Nigel's 9,000 views though a tremendous
ratio by the way these B that's crazy
too never kind of ratio it's almost
every single view like this well he was
number
um did he say smash that like button
perhaps he didn't even say that oh he
didn't even ask the audience to smash
the like button huh
I'm not seeing his first episode on
Spotify anymore just the second one
really is he ashamed of Nigel for some
reason but he left it on YouTube yeah
surely more people are watching it
there um there's more guys you're not
going to believe this which is really
funny Kevin Smith talks about investing
with Ryan Kavanaugh on his podcast it's
an old episode from wait the Kevin Smith
yeah the Kevin Smith what the [__] this
is from 2011 so it's not new but he does
mention him it's kind of just a weird
Wrinkle in
Time Kevin Smith of uh financially
cleric's Fame and right dogma and all
that
stuff so it was financially uh
beneficial like I was able to make sure
my investors got paid back that's
something you don't really get to do
where invest people invest in movies
movies is a bad investment you don't get
your money back you talked to old Ryan
Kavanaugh who runs what is it relativity
media if you if you're one of these rich
people that put money into to his
company like hey I'm put 50 million into
this company 10 years before you start
seeing it back even if they have hits
you know I mean he was actually been
optimistic I don't these people don't
they they actually went bankrupt right
when was it oh it says oh this is in
2011 yeah huh so yeah this would have
been at like his Peak really kavan's
Peak but he's trying to warn us he's
like yo if you give Ryan your money you
will never get it back he was right you
know it's it's you don't invest in the
movie business to get rich you invest in
the movie business if you want to hang
out with famous people who make movies
and [__] cuz if you want to get rich off
of it good [__] luck that's an
interesting observation he's definitely
right about that interesting but then
who's making all the money well the
studios and this because they don't need
investors well and because most movies
aren't
profitable it's all racket dude
oh oh yeah they make money M but as an
investor or if you say are an even an
actor writer on the movie and they give
you a deal that will give you a
percentage of the profits you will
likely never see anything because they
lost M on their billion dollars because
the movie was never technically
profitable huh they find ways of doing
write-offs and balancing it against
expenses for marketing and all kinds of
ways Hollywood accounting sounds like
Trump tax girl math yeah Hollywood math
girl math I don't know now I don't want
to insult the ladies I love girl math
yeah I love girl math I just learned
about girl math I've been getting all
those videos on my feet and I love I
don't know what that is but it's funny
it's like um can you explain G math yeah
it's like x + y equal or 2 plus 2 equals
5 because I want it to it's like that oh
it's like it's vies it's also like um
okay so a bag this bag costs $300 and I
technically cannot afford it but if you
split it divided by 30 you know like how
much does it cost you a day and then
divided by the hours you get to
something like five you get to something
like $5 and it's like oh I already spend
that on coffee I can AFF a day that's
easy or something like that I don't or
if you buy like a bag for $200 you
return it get the $200 back you just
made $200 that's amazing it's amazing I
can I give an example I feel like this
is a good girl math example and I'm new
to this so you guys tell
me if you see a super expensive piece of
clothing online $1,000 MH you would
never buy that ordinarily mhm but if
it's 15% off and so you say to yourself
well this is never going to be on sale
again and so basically by buying this
I'm saving myself $150 My Future Self
$150 therefore this is a good investment
and I'm going to buy this dress is that
good good girl math thing yeah also like
girl math would be if you pay with cash
it's like it feels like you're not
you're spending $0 since it's not on the
bill later like girl m
cash doesn't count it doesn't that's
really clever that's really clever
that's funny I love gold M what's boy
maath right what's boy girl what's boy
math really I do Wonder bro I just spent
177,000 on this roll it oh wait sorry I
mean not you
Zach I didn't mean I didn't mean that
targeted to you I but he wasn't there
crypto uh what is I'm talking more about
like uh Ryan's watch Zach and his shoard
yeah yeah that's that's boy ma a [__]
investment he's like oh here's boy math
he goes if I buy this $50,000 watch it's
going to pay off because people are
going to take me more seriously I'm
going to get more business people going
to look at me more respectfully and I'm
going to crush more [__] therefore boy
math checks out on the $50,000 R there
you go it is
$125,000
dunks the the the girl MTH is more fun
it's more aing I feel like um so that
was interesting also here's the big
um the main course this is the Brad the
bull it could be Ryan thank you AB it
could be Brad it could be somebody un
Associated well okay well there's a they
say they yeah yeah okay here's the post
is this Brad the bll undercover now
here's a
comment from almost a year ago I'm deep
300 days ago from a user named condition
wonderful 52 it's a that's a
autogenerated random throwaway yeah
similar to all of the comments on his uh
episodes too isn't that interesting what
do you mean John trial
37 John Cho whatever is that guy the
real deal yeah I think he writes in like
variety right so it's on a post titled
Brad the Bull's disappointment up close
this is when I said hey bro thanks for
taking care of her and he was like nah
dude so here's a comment I heard he was
like no dud taking care of bro I heard
Ryan and Brad went to high school
together and didn't see each other for
over 25 years Brad met his ex-wife and
asked Ryan for permission to date her
because he is a good guy we are all
giving him a hard time for no reason now
who the [__] would know that who would
know that and who would be worried about
like giving them a hard time for no
reason it feels very personal MH who the
hell would know all that now which we
should point out that was the
explanation that was given just
yesterday like verbatim so it's it's
correct information it's it's it's
precise for someone random to recall
this and why would they have known that
they wouldn't also if they would have
known that they wouldn't be
participating in giving him a hard time
I say we don't give him a hard time
that's why I we idolize him so that's
why I think that this isn't a fan
whoever commented
this can I say this I actually I don't I
think Brad's cool dude I have no Pro I
think Brad and frankly Ryan's ex-wife I
want to make it very clear that I think
they're both celebrated individuals and
by no means do I uh have any ill will or
judgment or and I and frankly I don't
think that uh anybody should I think
from what I can tell they're good people
good parents and uh they have strong
moral fiber and character besides being
friends and significant others as Brian
but you would have to ask that of
everyone in his life and that's just not
fair right we all have shitty friends
yeah right that's true and lovers thank
you but I feel like uh technically yeah
I don't think we even have really said
anything bad about him it's more so like
just making fun of the fact that he's
dating Ryan he's because it's because
he's this hunky [__] yeah Ryan
is this pasty goofy ass looking dude and
Brad is like the bull I mean he's this
hunky and he loves it you can see how he
talked about it he was the king in high
school and [__] like he loves it no he
didn't make Varsity in seventh grade
dude right but he came back he came back
in a big he eventually became the
captain he was the most popular dude in
school I heard that right yeah don't get
carried away but I i' I've intentionally
I saw comments like it sucks that Ethan
is going after Ryan's wife or ex-wife
and Brad because they didn't do anything
and and I
actually I feel that I've intentionally
throughout this whole thing
not gone after them or tried to insult
them I mean we don't even know anything
about them yeah I don't I don't know
them at all uh the only thing where
maybe it brushes close I think people
see it the wrong way is when I say like
oh Brad is and this is vulgar but I'll
say like Brad is screwing your ex-wife
but that that that's I know it's vulgar
and not a great way to describe you know
sex between a a a relationship a man and
woman as they say yeah qutis
consummation however it's more about the
idea it's not has nothing to do with her
I mean it could you know it could be a
trash can that Ryan was [__] rubbing
on before that now BR it doesn't matter
the point is is that Brad The Honky ass
bull is destroying the see is that mean
yeah that's
unnecessary Brad drops the Zar bomb on
her [__] every night wait I I think I
I have a sound that would that would fit
I like what it is for you is like
getting getting under Ryan's skin that's
all I well well I can see why you would
say that I I'm only here for fact
finding
and partial I just am curious about him
as a public figure Mur but if if you
were to say oh Ethan's trying to get
under anybody's skin it would definitely
be Ryan's and not theirs it was Mur yeah
and I think it's also because Ryan seems
so obsessed with like high school stuff
like were you cool in school or not what
makes you say that um he's his failure
pod I learned a lot inviting Mur
inviting his friend over to whine about
it for 2 hours yeah I learned a lot what
what makes you say that
Zach say what that he cares about high
school and popular and
stuff I said
that the most popular the coolest you
know kind of the bad boy getting a lot
of fights you know but you you have a
great time you love the party and you
you're so popular that might be my
favorite sound bite of the year it's so
[__] so bad so I feel like because of
that like using the fact that that his
friend is with his ex-wife is like and
we just learned that I didn't even know
they were like best they're like friends
that's the new re that's the new wrinkle
met when they were 13 it's almost like a
childish way of getting like insulting
him in in the insults that he kind of
cares about it seems right true does
that make sense yeah no it's not about
the two the two of them are fantastic I
and I want to emphasize that I truly
have nothing but frankly com uh if
anything a tremendous amount of empathy
and sympathy for them that they are in
one way or another uh related to Ryan
Cavanaugh and you know yeah that's a
bummer that's tough that's like a
handicap disability of some sort the
Epic photo we were talking about the
other days is in Discord I don't know if
you care to see that uh let's
see okay yeah and then like so yeah I
mean we show pictures like this but this
is all public by the way right I mean
this is all from their
Instagram page right yes yeah then he's
a public figure I cannot get over how
much he looks like my brother it it it's
truly phenomenal I was watching look
right here that's my brother he's your
brother but just like more he's bigger
dude he's like a lot more swole but in
the face they're straight up
doppelganger yeah that's weird kind I'd
frankly love to get him in the same room
because but that's that's obviously not
going to happen on both sides of the
aisle there but
maybe if there's like a we've always
joke about the the league of villains
getting
together I think there's something to it
man so what started as a joke but I'm
starting to believe so what's the
analysis I think we should acknowledge
this one thing Ethan though yeah about
the joking about them
um uh Charlie said it feels
chauvinistic and that's what I don't
want you to come off
as and I can see that so tell so walk me
through that because I I want to I don't
want to do that it's like she and her
and him are in a relationship
to to
participating humans M and it's like oh
he's he's railing
her it it feels a little bit like is it
the way I describe it it makes her it
makes her like an away like an object
that he took from him and he's railing
so do you have a suggestion for a better
way to to to basically to to emphasize
the humiliation that Ryan must
feel as a consequence of their
relationship she's so happy mhm she's so
fulfilled she's being she's being loved
the way she should that's actually
that's even more powerful I so that
resonates even more what if I say she's
getting really never mind she looks what
if I just do this what if I do
this murder make that sound and nothing
El murder it was murder in there like a
like a bowl I think they'll just they be
like
[Laughter]
it was more horike yeah it's confusing
who are we talking about that's three
for three then you're thank you love you
today
Zach so she okay I I I accept the
feedback yeah I I want you to not come
off that way cuz I know you're not that
way but I can see why it would come off
that way yeah okay good then I'm glad
I'm glad I brought this up because I
want to yes be doing the right thing yes
and um and show her the due respect that
I have for her right right it's still
she's choosing to be with him okay good
right and so it's like acknowledging
that she's Cho she was choosing to be
with him and of course she would I mean
look at it exactly you know I mean it's
not it wouldn't be insulting to her to
say she did a huge step up oh you can
say that I I believe you when you say
girl you step the [__] up I've also
noticed that uh this is this is a
[__] reach here but Brad's uh choice
of Footwear and watches are far Superior
than Ryan's I feel like Ryan is trying
to
over wait I he's over compensating can
you show me can you show me like um like
he his sneakers are cool he's got the
pair of like Travis Scots on where Ryan
goes and bu I do love the Travis Scots
$125,000 pair of duns he was wearing a
yeah and also like a super expensive
watch that Zach hates where Brad's taste
and watches he wears like an AP or like
a PCH F Brian has to get the more
expensive one that doesn't really make
it better he has he has no taste he has
no real class the only thing he
understands is money spending spending
so he's like oh this which is probably
why she realized that her relationship
with him would never be fulfilling
because he's as a human being probably
just more of a shell wow like an empty
shell of just someone who's obsessed
with money whereas Brad is somebody
who's not only wealthy and and for all I
know is the one of The Heirs to the
Basin Fortune but he's also successful
in his own right he's always closing and
he's a man of substance he was the most
popular in school he has great fashion
as Zach pointed out and he's and he's
hot as [__] yeah and his suits are
tailored better um Ryan just he's a
schlub he dressed absolutely schlub so
100% schlub so okay good so I mean girl
you go girl H yeah more power to
her yeah she looks so fulfilled she does
yeah she's glowing look at her glow yeah
exactly yeah she's got that glow
happiest she's ever been I think in a
sense this felt counter intuitive
because now I'm talking about her I see
even though it's complimentary and nice
but before I was like let's not focus on
her at all but you were still talking
about her in a right yeah yeah in
another way they look phenomenal
together so they're a beautiful couple
they're really pretty couple and then
there's
[Applause]
Ryan oh look at my sassy girl he looks
like uh her dad to be
honest what if we say she's so cool for
pimping these two hoes Ryan and she has
all the agency in that
[Laughter]
analogy I like that's powerful uh
circling back to the Legion of Doom I
sent something else above this photo I
don't know if you've seen this yet this
oh God I haven't showed it I've saw it
but I haven't shown it J shett get the
[__] out of my
life here they are with j shett and
Darman unbelievable two of the greats
what what's the context here clearly
she's like this is a very familiar thing
like you wouldn't do that unless you
were right homies with him right that's
not like a hey let's take a photo type
of thing is it no it's uh congrats on
the new podcast definitely like who are
they to congratulate them on their maybe
they're uh shed's realtor oh
maybe they sold Studio you invite your
realtor to your part I I do my business
and I move and I close the
book hang out you don't party anyway
with anybody so J shett do you ever see
your kids like I don't want to be such
an [__] but like bro you are out all
the
time you're always shooing somewhere
with somebody he's a wonderful father
he's always he's always shing with
always closing you know right nice
[Laughter]
yeah this it's crazy though just how Jay
Shetty is he always there everywhere he
will not go away dude he's God by gr
it's like he's made of magic yeah it
really is like that like moves in a Mist
it's incredible can we criticize Jay's
yellow shirt at all his choice of shirt
yes we can okay because it's looking
pretty weird it's not it's not working
for me frankly I love it I don't know I
honestly would need to see more I feel
like this might be a it might be the
theme of the party why I was thinking
that I was thinking maybe we need to
know more about it what the [__] Brad
wearing well look look how he dress
yellow in his pants yeah the pants are a
little bright I I think his fifth fire
it is a neon and his shoes yeah he he
looks great oh his shoes Cam that shirt
looks a little familiar that doesn't
that look familiar what that shirt that
J shed's wearing you're saying cuz I
wore the same similar one yesterday yeah
you we this
Yim you didn't it's an outfit thing it's
an outfit thing it's not what you wear
it's what you wear with it exactly you
look great I do think there's a good
chance there was a theme here okay
that's interesting so that [__] me up
and there's neon behind them but here's
the thing if you're going to a neon
theme party you should serve more than
this this is the least oh so now he's
not bright enough this guy can't
win what do you mean he can't win he
can't not win Dan that's the
problem what hasn't he won it looks like
there's some sort of logo in the
background B show let me look into it
looks like a reflection maybe uh didn't
um so Shetty and Darman have a a podcast
right so this was probably for the
premiere of that podcast is what I
suspect you think there's a realtor God
I think they invite the realtor to that
always closing baby well they're also
managed Talent as well I mean yeah Bryce
Hall met with James Charles before Oh I
don't know if that was a business
meeting but they posted a photo with him
so wait Brad knows James Charles oh yeah
there's another didn't Brad say he just
has he just manages Bryce
only to break into it somebody saying
that does it all he does it
all God that's your brother I don't give
a [__] what anyone
says that's your
brother I know you know like it's
weird all right thank you to them uh
let's let's continue down the vortex so
let's go on to the next
image Brad the Bull's disappointment up
close here's another comment he also
manages Bryce Hall his company is
Panther management I think what nobody
knew the name of his management company
nobody nobody he's not the bull he's the
panther now oh oh here's another one
another Brad the pole related post
comment Brad the PLL Brad the the bull
immediately regretting his decision to
answer his phone here's another comment
agreed it's [__] up
Ryan and Brad knew each other in high
school but weren't still friends hadn't
seen each other in 25 years when Brad
met Jessica you know all their names
yeah you know every [__] detail and
also why do you
care who do you think this is listen I
don't know for sure but I have a reason
to
it be well let narrow it down who this
intimate amount of knowledge that not as
as I know Ryan or Brad or cares this
much about
it Jessica's a queen she wouldn't bother
with this I don't think she would no so
is it Ryan or is it Brad in your opinion
well let's keep going yeah there's a lot
more here's more does nobody else have
an ex-wife that has a new boyfriend
what's special about this he seems like
a nice
guy that sounds like Ryan right I don't
know but there's more also how does he
seem like a nice guy we've never at this
point we never really interaction we
just saw photos of him well Bryce said
Bryce said Brad was a great guy on that
episode true Bryce loves Brad Bry loves
Brad yeah he was talking him up
yeah yeah here okay so now we're moving
on to episode two
this person now fast forward 300 Days is
now commenting on another Brad post he's
a unit for sure hot as [__] obsessed
that now what do we make of this now I
have no idea what to think if it's Brad
it's weird to say that about yourself if
it's Ryan it's weird then we have a red
alert I think if it's either it eats I'm
obsessed like that type of self love is
really beautiful he's a unit hot as [__]
have we considered it might be Bryce
himself
might be Bryce I don't even think Bryce
knows all that I don't think he
cares you know what I mean Bryce is like
oh yeah no Jessica met him 25 years ago
and they're best friends and they had
this it's like no Bryce doesn't care he
doesn't listen I feel like Bryce is the
kind of guy who's like probably heard
all of it but he wouldn't know it he
wouldn't know to repat he's the coolest
he's like whatever babe
coolest um and then another comment from
the same person not going to lie I would
bang him yep that is so
cool also
using now I'm lost now I don't know if
this is suggested but they used the
acronym not going to lie NGL the
question is does Ryan is he does he know
like internet
vernacular and stuff I have a counter
theory if you're trying to act like
you're someone young you might put it
and then you might capitalize it because
you never use I was to say the same
thing the capitalization seems kind of
Boomer to me I me Ryan does say link he
also says these balls yeah like he says
up he's like Po Uplink post and Uplink
this up Uplink wait in what year was
that appropriate Uplink like I don't
know 2015 what does even mean lot people
in the chat think 2005 they there's a
lot of support in the chat for being
Jessica a I don't see it well that
honestly of all the things that would be
the least cringy yeah that would be the
least cringey at this point yeah I don't
see her saying this Stu listen I don't
know anything about her but I know she's
a queen and she's always closing by the
way the name always closing isn't that a
little patronizing of like your clients
you're like I always closing on these
[__] like it makes them look it makes
them look like they don't give a [__]
they only care about closing the deal
and it's weird I it's weird to take that
from a movie like it's such a popular
line in a movie always be closing yeah
and it's about like scumbag psychotic
salesmen who don't care about anything
and if you don't make a sale you don't
even get coffee coffee is for winners
yeah exactly everybody's saying it's to
be the wife I just don't see it m it's
well yeah it's that there's more though
isn't there and this [__] guy I think
there is let me see well there's more on
the maybe the obvious answer is the
answer well what's the obvious answer in
my opin the wife is the obvious cuz like
I would bang
him yeah the funniest answer could
though is r and I want to go with that
one let me put it this way I guess the
the one I guess the easiest as you said
is
Jessica the
cringiest is Brad the funniest is Ryan
yes right yeah so pick
your and by the way it could be somebody
else oh yeah they explain how they know
this all this
information this is
great oh wait hold on there was a post
you guys saw we saw where people were
calling this user out like why do you
know why you commenting on pictures of
Brad and why do you know so much about
him and then this user goes on to
explain
how they know all this okay I'm going
through their comment history I heard
they were erasing comment so I don't
know we have it all okay yeah we have we
backed it up she doesn't seem to be like
the type of person to be watching and
spending time on Reddit yeah I don't
she's the one that's like Brad and Ryan
you guys got to stop caring about that
dude she's like the voice of reason and
I feel like even Brad I don't see doing
that so Co it kind of leaves me only
with Ryan and we know that Ryan is Con L
on the internet he's
constantly he's obsessed with everything
you know he's made we have evidence to
suggest that on Wikipedia he had
multiple accounts and sock puppets that
he was using to manipulate his page that
was the in the words of the Wikipedia
mods in the edit history Wikipedia I
have that all correct yeah he was banned
for I'm hearing reports that Wikipedia
is not real though Wikipedia is like not
real okay well that's an interesting
counter argument however we know that he
is capable of
such right wait there's a wild card
guess
here this could be
Ethan
yo not going to lie how would I know
that that how would I know all that info
that's true you didn't know this I can
vouch for that true there's not many
people in this world it could be
honestly not
many there's like three people in this
world that this could be isn't that
[__] crazy like the story doesn't
stop
giving it really is it is truly
something man it's been astounding I
mean at a certain point I'm just going
to have to say this whole thing was
worth has been worth it I mean is it may
like if you break it down no don't say
it we don't we don't we do our shows
regardless it's got I mean that's true
we'll be here every day regardless no um
financially it's been a terrible
decision for me okay fair enough for
sure it comes nowhere near and it's
still not even done it's not going to be
done forever also I I don't think you
could look at an episode with him and
say oh that Prophet goes because like we
do episodes every day regardless of what
we're talking about yeah but even if you
did do that it' be nowhere close and um
fair enough yeah you know so here is oh
this is from 19 hours ago another Wild
Card Guest The Nanny The Nanny he never
paid he might know that
she wants to [__] Brad up this okay so
hold
on this is their Post
history uh the the title of the post is
Brad the bull is lurking
here yeah and I I don't know if we
actually mentioned this yet apologies if
we did but um this person's POS hisory
was devoid of anything other than
talking about Brad and like on our
subreddit so there was like two comments
about in a skateboarding
subreddit every other comment and
interaction was in our subreddit
specifically about post with Brad in it
and about Brad
yeah but here's the thing if it was Ryan
I feel like he wouldn't just be
defending Brad Brad the if it was briyan
he'd be more interested in like
defending
himself therefore actually you know what
I'm thinking it's I'm thinking Brad's
the most likely maybe once Brad realized
people are on to him then he started
saying the stuff like not going to lie I
would bang him to make it seem like oh
you think that might be trying to throw
people off cuz that is what threw me off
at first I thought it was him for sure
that could be actually could
be so um here's here's some of the
comments where's the one where they gets
called out though I don't see that how
they know this
information I didn't see that to be
honest uh I give me a minute I have the
whole back up right here though s you
Dan I was looking at it last night they
talk about it in the
end uh Brad wasn't friends with Ryan but
knew him from high school he met Jessica
Kavanagh randomly and they discovered it
so Brad told her he needed Ryan's
permission to take her out it's actually
cool of Brad after seeing the podcast
I'm a fan seems down to earth and humble
and he's hot as [__] they were separated
then too so not like Brad broke them up
or anything dude what the hell are the
coolest
the chances that that's Brad are
increasing in my mind no kind of the bad
boy oh man kind of the bad boy you know
what he's convincing me I'm a fan I love
Brad great dude in the podcast where he
said like two lines he's like I'm a fan
yeah if watching I'm a huge fan you know
kind of the bad boy I wonder if I think
this is the one you were talking about
right uh is it this button
yeah yeah so here so in response to that
comment somebody wrote why do you know
so much about Brad you actually only
talk about him all your comments over a
year are only about him like if I was
Brad I'd be scared of you and then they
responded to this okay explaining how
they know this
information right let me see if I have
that
one that was just a screenshot I had
sent I was looking at it last night when
we were talking about it it came out
yeah there was a lot of links going back
and forth our our group chat last night
was
we were having a good time with this
discovery you know but there was a
really interesting cover
story um for how they know this
information and we we need to decide how
credible it is really
absolutely
absolutely all right I'm looking at the
full comments here find I probably
forwarded it to the research oh here it
is here it is absolutely I got it
absolutely thank you I can even just
pull it up here
one second it's this one right here my S
so here's what they said in
response my sister went to school with
them and told me they weren't even
friends in high school but since Brad is
a good guy he asked for permission when
he found out her ex was a guy he knew
and now he gets this and the girl gets
talked about the worst I don't know any
who would do
that this is low key T if Brad wrote
this and that's
deleted that one's deleted oh
interesting this one's deleted so what
do you is this a is this a plausible
story I was my older sister knew them in
high school and that's how I know all
this no that seems farfetched As [__]
how would they know the company show me
it again how would they know how long
they knew each other they were friends
for 25 years he asked permission how
would you know any of that
doesn't really make sense and why would
all their comments be about this this is
also wouldn't that hurt Ryan's feelings
to read that that Brad said um we
weren't friends in high school no they
talked about it show said weren't
friends he said we weren't really
friends in high school we knew each
other and also the logic of my sister
went to school with them and like now
the comments defending Ryan's ex but
half of the comments from this person is
saying I want to bang Him Sister which
weird yeah dude I feel like there's no
way that that story is possible no like
can you think of one those of you with
older siblings think about someone they
knew in high school and how much you
know about their intimate life with
another person that they knew and that
you know every detail about their dating
history especially if they weren't even
friends they just knew of each other
even if this person was like I went to
school with them that's how I know I
would find that
hard to believe which is really funny
cuz then you're making a Reddit account
25 years later just to comment on this
specific situation and only this
situation dude I think it's I think
based on the available evidence and of
course I don't know for sure because
this is all just speculation Anonymous
but it seems to me that Brad I think
this is Brad you think it's Brad if I
had to if I had to guess the identity
unfortunately that does seem more likely
which is really embarrassing for him
embarrassing I thought it was Ryan when
we first started talking about it but
I'm thinking more Brad now he's online
talking about how he won't [__] himself
yeah I kind of love his work honestly
you're into it yes it is kind of gets
into pathology a little bit because you
look at him like he has everything in
life he was popular he gets the girl
he's successful but it's not ice cream
Fortune dude yeah he's still insecure he
still has to go and talk about or maybe
he's narcissist I don't know and of
course this is all based on to all
speculation here I don't know from what
I understand Brad's a really cool and
sweet dude he's sick and hot he's
popular sick hot and popular oh speaking
of sick hot and popular what's up
Gabe so when did I end up
getting a haircut
yeah what what do we get
extra oh hell yeah okay okay what the
hell what kind of Chanel looking good
Gabe oh no gab boy talk to me hey what's
going on I like the fresh cut bro yeah
just start me on
mute we can hear you can you not hear us
can you hear us Gabe Oh shoot
no is everything okay what's happening
let's see mute am I on mute no we can
hear you we hear
you let me see if it might be on our
side he's not coming out of the zoom
channel uh AB can you unplug repug in
maybe just leave it I kind of like
it just leave him freaking out like that
let's see where it
goes damn I'm no look the Scarlet just
hook back up it should you hear us now
now I can hear you oh there he what's up
G Friday every buddy happy Friday I love
your new your haircut looks fresh as
hell mhm thank you thank you I'm trying
cheesy calone from Papa John it's it's
like the best really let me see
yeah let me see that
[__] okay Papa's making czon now huh
yeah great is that a shack Innovation
you think is that
new it must be a new item yeah you
remember Papa John's the um you remember
the [__] Pizza salad made me oh [__]
I guess they sto with those eh yeah
thank God that was a that was really a
low point for Humanity it was
slop so gabo how did I wanted to know
how did the the the spaghetti turnout
last Friday oh but turn out they posted
a video with posted on on Instagram and
it turn not great did you try phenomenal
nice the best I remember when you were
pouring garlic powder there was an
overspill did that that but that did not
have an effect on the product it
actually improves The Taste actually was
good it turned out to be good turn out
great nothing too much about something
that makes it
good that looked so good I'm mistaken
they still have the POA bowls disgusting
sorry
so what's going on okay not much buddy
oh you hear that did you feel the
earthquake I didn't feel nothing oh
there was a pretty big earthquake like
an hour or two ago a 5.0 in Thousand
Oaks really yeah I didn't feel nothing I
thought I hear one in Hawaii 4.0 or
something pretty Hawaii got one at the
same time no I think it was this
morning how big was one in
Hawaii to the um Instagram news and
stuff what does it mean we're dying
is both places all the time they're I'm
doubtful they're related but they are
part of the same tectonic plate I think
the ring of
fire is a big ring around the Pacific
Pacific Ocean that goes on California
and Japan there's a ton of earthquakes
around yeah alas
Japan of fire mhm sounds so cool the
ring of fire it's where the tectonic
plates meet
and it's pretty
crazy did have the ring of fire I'm
pretty sure that's where like the vast
majority of all earthquakes are is on
the ring of
fire in the current phase of the Earth
where we are
today Earth is like moving furniture
that's what I call it the Earth moving
furniture what is your thoughts on
Pangia Pangia it's like a um it's like a
super
wow true a super continent breaking up
it's like all you put all the couches
and tables together and you try to
spread them out that's what I call a
Pangia dude that's awesome Yep actually
I like the way you described it to a
super continent I think that's like
actually the way the scientists talk
about it I'm getting
educated you're a smart guy uh Gabe you
study I used to study as a kid you know
science and stuff and I used I know
school it's stuff that interesting about
the Earth about the geology about life
the dinosaurs and [__] [__] [__] for
sure dude [__] yeah dinosaurs are like
the major they're like the animals
before human dinosaurs are like you know
the men of the prehistoric times that's
what I think human
beings um do you have a favorite
dinosaur I'd say the
Brontosaurus my man
the thing is about the Bron shout out
dude that that dinosaur was the the it
dinosaur when we were a kid but since
then I don't know if you know they found
dinosaurs that are way bigger for
example the Argentinosaurus is like
twice as Big M I called the giant
lizards giant you know what um T the
Tyrannosaurus Rex stands for tyrant
Lizard
King oh the king the Emperor of
dinosaurs people mhm that rule the world
you obey them or you or you get punished
or die that's
right kiss the claw
[Laughter]
[__] very cool
man you want to ask that AB I was just
asking if you felt the earthquake AB
wants to know he because we've haven't
mentioned this AB wants to know if you
felt the earthquake oh did you mention
it went oh hold on and Gabe I apologize
if you've already talked about this this
is a 4-Hour show so sometimes I go to
the bathroom which I did and then I came
back and being such a nice guy I I
brought some cake for I gave Olivia a
piece then I came I was like oh I wonder
how he came around and offered me some
as well yeah yeah I offer everyone cake
and then I sat down and I missed I
missed that you guys mentioned it so I
did you offer Ethan no I didn't get any
offers guess what you have to admit AB
that the frequency of this is is making
a good opportunity for for mhm cont I
have a response the more you do the more
margin for error oh oh wow he came ready
he came from Ready for War today it
doesn't make it less funny doesn't make
could be funny I'm just I'm explaining
more for the audience not for
you they know I love
it
did you want some cake
Ethan he's good what's the story with
the
cake what's funny G I was having I was
having a serious
what the [__] was that you're laugh at
me as I'm
dying all right Gabe listen I hope you
have a fantastic weekend full of love
and laughter
yeah enjoy the Super Bowl baby the Super
Bowl who weing for who you roting for
dude I got to go with the Chiefs and
momes Cat bet against momes baby how do
you like um Taylor Kelsey or whatever is
that his name Travis Kel
Kelsey's is he man he is the man he's
gonna he's gonna he's gonna make some
touchdowns and you know entertain us all
yes and what do you think about his um
his dating
life that I can't I I don't pay
attention to it so I have no clue about
can I ask you this who do you know who
he's dating I have no clue oh wow would
it surprise you if I told you he's
dating Taylor Swift
oh Taylor Swift wow I didn't know about
that czy I thought that's like I thought
that's Taylor Swift's Idol or something
that's they're dating yeah pretty crazy
okay okay not bad huh
Travis child is Kelsey all right have
fun go
Chiefs Chiefs baby all way go Chiefs
next year's theet next year's the Jets
year Gabe Jets year next here baby jet
good let's see what they'll do might be
the magical year the Jets 2024 is going
to be a rebuilding year or a year of
change yep I I can feel it did we talk
about who's going to do the performance
on this Sunday I think they Taylor Swift
is just GNA Sub
in do you know who I don't know who
who's do us Usher dude the Super Bowl no
off no offense of Usher I mean he's a
great performer it's just the choices
are often seem so Random yeah we kind of
had this discussion in the office a
little bit but Usher I mean Usher is
huge I mean he hasn't had a big hit in a
while but no he yeah he's the man he's
the man should have been [__] Creed
dude also he's like 60 and he looks like
20 did you know that he's like old as
[__] and he looks so damn young he just
did a skims ad skims yeah he's ripped
yeah he's ripped of course he is he's
always been ripped 45 I don't know I
found it a little weird I guess we'll
see we'll see how much we enjoy he'll
Crush it's going to be awesome probably
are we going to see his dick like a
malfunction
definitely go ahead Gabe I'm just going
to eat some you want to take
over well i' say the dick is a powerful
weapon got to control that
thing
true how do we control
it just
emotions and what's powerful about
it it's something that you make make
someone feel um feel
Lov oh right that's how I've always
described
it it's the Brontosaurus of the
[Laughter]
body all right we're going to start
talking about horsecock do you want to
stick around that
or there you go
yeah all right Gabe listen we love you
we all love you I love you Ethan you
guys are awesome have a
great
weekend let's go baby maybe people maybe
there's some Chief fans that want a Gabe
shout out from Cameo for the Super
Bowl
right sure oh yeah definitely
gock
baby all right Gabe we love you okay
have a great weekend all right all right
buddy talk to you
soon Gabe everybody that was Uncle
Gabe the artist formerly known as
whiteclaw so yeah this this whole this
thing tickled my [__] fancy because
it just it never ends with this
story I freaked out I saw it I was
browsing the subred it didn't have a lot
of points somehow and I sent it
immediately in the chat with tons of
sirens and that was a warranted one
right Dan oh yeah yeah no that was siren
worthy okay good I get mad cuz sometimes
he gets a little too fast and loose with
the sirens and it gives me a panic
attack whenever I see that yeah I'll
when you drop the sirens that's like a
moment I'll pull
over me too by the way I put everything
down you never know you never know what
just happened my heart beats so
quick we respect the siren Emoji always
sometimes I get to do the ey Emoji
before you actually say what's going on
he still typing I love that cuz I know
it's a captive audience the bet there's
like a few second delay where everyone's
and you're typing yep very exciting I
can't wait to see you know what's
interesting is if Ryan
or Bryce see this and then they're going
to be like yeah this has to be Brad like
what's the deal Brad why why you being
such a
weirdo drive a wedge between this Trio
not at all but there if anyone's in a
position to
question uh the origins of this user it
would certainly be Bryce or Ryan
Kavanagh right or Jessica but I don't
think she's involved
no I mean would she even know all this
like even she wouldn't know all the damn
like high school lore she wouldn't give
a [__] about that know she but she she
says it like whoever wrote this says it
like they've they've typed it a thousand
times right he said that
um Ryan or I forget who exactly said it
but so Brad wanted a dinner with Ryan to
ask his permission to date his ex I
think she she was the one that uh or he
suggested it and she brought it up to
him I think so she knew they they knew
each other since high school well
unfortunately since we called it out
this user is probably going to disappear
but
um if not if you Brad if you do want to
continue if that is Brad we will be
watching maybe this is way we could
secretly
communicate right that' actually be
pretty useful you know like in the Cold
War how Russia and us had like a secret
phone line yeah to prevent like nuclear
Holocaust mhm me and Brad have
going Earth Cafe sent us all kinds of
extra [__] what is that look how weird
that looks it's like a bakaba
cake it was a celebration of the
earthquake you you want me to bring
might be because they kept canceling out
orders L has been trying to order for
like an hour from them here's Gabe with
his favorite bronchos
orus king of the dinosaurs long neck
baby all right so what's
left oh there's so much we got to talk
about Taylor so we have Taylor it's kind
of set up we have
vosm and we have James let's do a poll
Taylor I'm dying BOS uh Taylor and I'm
dying to talk about J yeah Theos thing
is pretty fun I I'm not going to lie
Theos thing is the mo some of the most
shocking Clips I've ever seen it really
is unreal yeah people actually saying
this [__] online in this ho year
mhm at this big age Taylor Swift versus
Seline BOS Bou whatever the [__] this or
should I take it and
uh oh James James Charles
mhm all right let's see what the people
want some [__] we'll try to get to
all of
them but trying to make it we got huge
categories to get to
I'm desperate oh Mama Mia the people
know it's interesting I wonder if we
need to change the titles vosch was
looking at
what that's pretty good let's get
Glam let's get some dubs in chat for
horse
porn can we get some hor emojis going on
in the chat please
L poor
BOS all right
well people say I don't know who Bosch
is but you convinced me I want to hear
it this is going to be good I mean you
guys are really going to lose your minds
here but we're going to do a fair shake
that was my you know what we wanted to
clickbait the Super Bowl we forgot about
that uh right that was the original
intent with the uh do you think Super
Bowl or vosch is a better title or a
better title than what we have Super
Bowl if I'm being honest jrv NBR a lot
of people don't know who he is so I
don't know how much the name not a huge
Creator he's a big Creator he's big just
I guess in our audience probably most
know but not as big as a horsecock but
big not just the right vosch no bucket
is required oh no the Vos situation is
more exciting than the Super Bowl you're
both in there you're both how about this
the Voss situation gave me stiff person
disease oh god syndrome oh yeah
combining both stories cleverly
NBR lot of horses in the chat all right
so I'm going in the chat all right I'm
going to go to the bathroom and then
when I come back we'll get into Vos okay
copy that hey everyone hi Dan how's it
going great yo what's going on cam we
climbing later you want to go climbing I
do I've been feing to climb so uh I was
thinking about it cuz the rest of the
gang that we go climbing with um uh was
texting and asking but technically today
is the last day that I'm supposed to not
do physical act they said four days oh
no we can't climb for uh for the wisdom
teeth extraction I feel fine I feel like
I could but if I'm listening to my to my
doctor I'm not supposed to dentist
orders dude we can't climb today we can
go climbing this weekend though let's go
climbing tomorrow let's go climbing
tomorrow let's go climb dude Cam and I
are climbing Ian's climbing too but
Ian's Ian's he's not here here you know
what you could climb what can you climb
can climb over the door cuz Zack Lewis
live with the echo PL
yo [__] got him dude tickets on sale
now nicely done nicely done nicely done
uh let me see if I can find some of
these super chats that we could read out
I'm
doing I'm doing the switching today
you're doing a great job always thank
you thank you juggle right now I know
I'm no
uh no Ian I'm definitely Rusty you know
I used to switch all the time people
newer fans might not know that but I
originally switched and then I trained
Ian to do it because it's hard to switch
and talk on the show at the same time um
but then Ian had such a pension for it
that I was like well [__] he's he's good
at this keep him on the
switching uh can we get another crew
swap segment now that Love's here we're
kind of doing it right now in a way
that's true doing Ian's job uh yeah love
did not participate in that did he they
did not it would be fun to force love
we've been trying to slowly go through
all those old segments crew segments
that love missed out on and do them in
fact I think we have a rematch on the
compliment battle coming up uh pretty
soon here which people will remember
love took the dub in but there was a lot
of controversy around that decision
because people felt like he had an
unfair Advantage being bullsh on the
robot just to the theme of today's
episode that's some hor [__] that's not
some hor [__] brother some hor [__] it
was a little bit hor [__] I just don't
laugh yeah I mean you do you are you
have
the all the
time I gigle I find it hard that someone
can be Ian to be honest I feel like Ian
Ian is the driest of all of us for sure
if I don't want to laugh I don't
know it's kind of like a Swedish
superpower to be serious so yeah you
know not me I'm the worst I laugh at
funerals oh I'm I'm the same way I laugh
at everything dude it's so I don't know
yeah just like when I know I'm not
supposed to laugh it's [__] tough
well might be rough for you I'm going to
go out first round straight up you think
so ah dude I laugh at everything you can
move your finger around and all laugh
yeah I'm bad about it too I'm not good
at at hold holding my laugh so I'm not I
don't have High Hopes don't have high
hopes for this competition but anyways
yes we'll be doing that uh
this this coming week actually we have a
lot scheduled next week
too um there's a potentially a huge huge
red alert sirens in the chat Banger
episode a week from today next Friday
but I'm not going to tell you what it is
I don't know what but there's something
something big in the works what's that I
don't know what's in the works uh I'll
I'll tell you uh in
Discord in just a
moment the big thing is Zack Lou is life
with the Echoplex you know that's the
big news that's what's happening you see
that
ah got it so a lot of work been put into
this one so it should be fun so yeah
that's coming up next week and then yeah
uh next Wednesday like we said earlier
is Valentine's Day and I guess we're
kicking off this whole Jeff thing
boy unfortunately Ian and St are both
not here
today Ethan real real quick you were
about 5 Seconds off with the song Oh
[__] should I go back and come out yeah
you want to try again it's pretty close
no it definitely very close um all right
vosch so once again let me set this up
vosch fans please know this we are going
into this with the most
partial and best intentions to
represent you say partial or impartial
we are impartial we are partial to the
truth okay
fair we're going to show the context of
everything so that we can make the best
informed
decision let's get more horses in chat
before we start please everybody got the
horses in the chat oh yeah can we get
horses and eggplants in the chat
please um and
corn let's do horse eggplant corn can we
get that
please all right let me put this
away sorry about
that all right
BOS it's
exciting I was really enjoying all this
it's just so phenomenal so let's start
from the beginning
so go ahead Vos recently it was a few
yesterday or the day
before he ended his stream in a panic
after he accidentally
exposed his corn
folder maybe do like a one liner of who
is vaj because um can see this is sure I
mean yeah we don't normally talk about
him yep I'm looking yes sir I guess we
got the button yeah it's censored it's
censored I did it myself yeah and by the
way well in the actual picture is there
even anything that is like Mega vulgar I
think so there is okay okay yeah there's
enough there that is the problem
Co so here is a clip of the end of his
stream the other day y YouTube chat is
filtering all of the
uh horse corn eggplant Emoji combo what
it's like getting hidden Auto hidden in
the chat I can see what are they running
defense for Vos what's the deal here
maybe it's just too spammy with Emojis
so that it's a secret language that
where we're finding out mod if we if we
could manually go through and show all
of
these so here's what happened and again
Vos fans if you want to defend him I'm
going to be receptive to everything
you're saying I'm not here with an
agenda I'm just showing something funny
that
happened okay but I will say this what
was on the agenda this is what socialism
does to
[__] no I'm kidding we love the
socials he's just a political
commentator right so he's a he's a
political commentator he's a leftist a
socialist and uh he is pretty popular in
that space I mean there's like probably
three main political lefties which is
like Hassan Vos and Destiny MH so he's
part of that
Trinity he's one of the main guys got it
not like Mega popular because obviously
it's a niche but but he's very popular
in that space I mean his videos get
hundreds of thousands of views sometimes
a
million here it is you can see this is
an example of the kind of structure that
I'm referring to
what now the sound now is that how the
stream
ended uh I'm not 100% sure lot when
people were posting it on Twitter that's
how they labeled it but um I think if I
remember I think it cut to like a a
holding card some sort of static holding
card for a moment and then it ended
shortly after that so one more
time so this is how this is an example
of the kind of structure that I'm
referring to
what that's a face of a man who
[Laughter]
knows no now traditionally we've caught
conservatives Porn Stash it happened to
um Alex Jones and also
yes to uh what's that other [__] bag
that was friends with Kanye Fuentes they
right they both did his trans porn yeah
fenes was looking at trans there was
like a trans thing with him too yeah I
don't remember but but so I was I was
saying yesterday the left L Hitler they
so on the right they secretly they want
to they're Chasers I think they call
them they want to be with trans
women right on the left they want to
[__]
horses
I want to see Hassan's private folder
now we need to [__] get to the bottom
of
this but we all have secrets don't we so
he he panics and it couldn't be funnier
frankly you can see this is an example
of the kind of structure that I'm
referring
to oh God I didn't get to see his face
it happens so quickly yeah it does it
happens fast so here is an enhanced
version of the it's the thing I'm not I
obviously can't put this on screen but
El I'll show it to you oh so I'll
describe it to you guys so it's a
folder oh is this the super high res one
that you found uh love yeah I think so
so it say old oh yeah you're there's a
there's a higher resan guys I just found
this leaked photo oh no dude h no
explain this [__] now this is when he
realized he was a socialist right here
there's no such thing as a coincidence
look at him on that horse too he looks
comfortable
Hy oh no this [__] rode horses
as a kid I mean we talked about it many
times Pony ass Pony Express ass looking
Pony Express you you just uh revealed
that you're afraid of horses right Ethan
I'm not afraid of horses I just think
they're powerful you they they should be
respected not [__] around with okay
yeah no that's 100% fair and true I said
they are scary like if you you don't
want to stand behind a horse you'll die
I got bit by a horse oh [__] what I
didn't know they did that my dad had
listing on a property that a bunch of
horses and this big [__] like Arabian
horse just came up and just [__] bit
my arm BR on the Arabian
horse hey anti-semitic horse you know
but every time I'm next to a horse in
real life I'm always struck by how
massive and like muscular they are
they're really their [__] are yeah I
didn't look at their
[__] listen I'm a Social Democrat we
don't look at yeah we don't you don't
look at what's under the
hood here's a uh here's a picture of
great communist leaders oh wow there is
a connection here great communist
leaders of our time uh Kim jnun Putin
Alex Jones interesting one but and then
Hassan okay Putin is definitely not a
communist leader well we like to
consider him part of the
uh I think this is just a bunch of babes
like a bunch of hotties okay well it's a
child calm down well he grew into a
babe we didn't get to the Lolly stuff
yet not yet
right but it is in there it's all good I
can't get I can't get a hold of myself
all right Focus you so here's Ela I
don't know what I'm looking at so it's a
bunch of folders first of all there's
five folders yeah dude love there's got
to be a clear one I know I saw a clear
one than this well I sent you well I
don't know which one you're looking at
got isn't Mega here's the full one okay
here you porn this is much better thank
you so there's old there's a folder says
old this this document is called to be
sorted there's five folders in it old
taxes
XXX gifts XXX pic and XXX vids XXX
tacon so organized and now you get to
the kind of
unsorted downloaded images that are
populating
miscellaneous and it's yet to be sorted
now the first thing I'm noticing is a
king garu from Legend the new Legend of
Zelda and it appears to be I can't be
sure but it appears to be king garu porn
and Dan pointed out king garu is Hors
like he has equin like features yeah go
off King I don't know if he's supposed
to be like a horeman but when we were
trying to figure out if that's what it
was uh and I pulled up a picture I was
struck by how horike his face is so I
mean I'm you know what I mean so like I
don't know just trying to [__] uh King I
mean he was powerful k King raru he he
had a lot of power and he was Charming
King but physically he's not my type
here let's let's pull him up and you all
tell me if I'm off base with the with
the horse comparison here going we'll
get to that yeah I know we'll get to
that I guess he's more like a deer it's
like a you pull it up I can't see yeah
I'm trying to that's King raru what do
we think that's the one he fos wants to
[__] oh it's definitely horike you think
it's horik de deer likee maybe yeah
maybe it's like a deer definitely not
human right yeah [__] go yeah it's a
little [__] you're right he's goated
maybe he is goated so there's that and
then we move to the other parts and love
you've you kind of know the specifics
about the what's in here not not saying
anything but you did you are boots on
the ground you put it yeah yesterday
when we were talking about it on the
live stream I found a Twitter thread
saying that one of the animes depicted
in these thumbnails are apparently of a
the main character in that anime is 16
which is quite deeming my it's it is a
sex series from based on what I saw no
so there's an anime of it and I guess
this is a sexual version of okay so in
the anime she is specifically 16 years
old porn has a porn of that character
and there's a photo I saw that was
like there's the one I saw on your that
you showed me AB yeah that ela's got to
see that when you go below 16 like 15
and stuff like that that but here it
gets kind of hard to see cuz it's so
small but here I mean it just looks
like hentai here's some horse big ass
horsecocks here's a girl treating a
horsecock here's a horsecock silhouette
with a big horsecock here's more Lord
rahu Fairy stuff you see the horse here
oh and then this is a horse dick got it
yeah and
then this is
um this stuff is super graphic actually
line dogac pony soldier um it gets a
little hazy here yeah can you fill in
the blanks what am I looking at like on
the bottom row the bottom
row okay nothing about nobody this is
the cartoon character that's
16 let me D I don't want to say for sure
but I believe so do you see this yeah
this what do you think of that 16 is
that's vile I don't like it it looks
like
[Music]
a 14-year-old girl
yeah it's it's really and then here's
another one this one was on there too of
the same
character so those are the
images um that we
saw there's and um also shout out he has
his taxes there which I think is
interesting and clever it ensures he
does not forget
you he gets audited to pay his taxes
he'll never lose it there he gets
audited and he his F you know like he's
like I'm not going to lose this [__]
going in my porn stash yeah to be fair
this is stuff he had to like take care
of
Legally
possibly oh it's a
vtuber not Nat sururu maturi maybe some
people know who that is I don't know but
here you can I'll show you the picture
of her she is like clear
a child age 16 it say here but that's
like a that's like a young 16 too I feel
like
oh so he has some very graphic oh sorry
yeah it's just this oh I didn't realize
what you were pulling up yeah this is
just okay to the page about the
character's
virtual she's a vtuber I guess or I
don't I don't know what all that means
but Goa yeah gotcha
personality
NRI is an energetic expressive and
somewhat chaotic cheerleader girl who is
bubbly as a
festival us I've read enough the way a
lot of [__] weirdos get away with
kind of stuff like this is they say in
the lore this character is like a
billion years old like
a but then like it looks like a [__]
infant or some [__] so wait in this
though she's not she's in this case it's
even worse cuz it's like confirmed she's
16 and pretend looks mine yeah and in
the fold the picture from the horse
files she looks even younger honestly
that one's really [__] up there's one
of her correct me if I'm wrong fading a
horse I can't okay cuz it's blurred the
clearer version but she's doing that to
someone I can't tell if it's a hairy man
or a horse
okay I mean foro that's that to me is
enough I've seen
enough no no one was harmed in the
production of this mhm I was and seeing
it I don't know if that
counts but let's move on because that's
not this is it only gets better from
here really I haven't watched wait
what
yeah um I'm only looking at what was in
his
folder that's it I have not yeah anyway
so this led people to compiling
questionable clips from vos's past
apparently he has a colorful history of
saying really
bizarre creepy weird [__] it's rewind
time now this is the one that people say
is always um taken out of context so
let's do our best
here to uh give its full due so here
should consume now here's a compilation
okay so if there's anything out of
context here let me know this is was
made by the YouTube police
department that's an I've never heard of
them aab
tter of course you're aab means you two
police too okay wow cavab really you
going to call aab on
them that says a lot 14-year-old Natalie
Portman so here's some of the uh
Greatest Hits let's listening child porn
be legal I think that that would be yes
more legal and more ethically consistent
yes 100% listen very carefully to the
exact language that I use I have yet to
hear a convincing moral or legal
argument as to why possession of child
pornography should be illegal the
argument that I was making and I've made
this argument a bunch of times and I've
addressed this poorly made argument a
bunch of times here why is the
possession of child pornography immoral
people are inconsistent in their moral
outrage at Commodities which hurt people
when they're produced so people will
laugh off cocoa butter or chocolate or
um you know or or Cobalt or other you
know products that we tend to get
through a really really unethical system
but then they're really really quick to
well we have a we do as a we do have a
special place in our heart for child
rapists is seriously trying to make a a
chocolate you eat chocolate but you
don't but you you dare to care about
child pornography and you eat
chocolate you're going to sit there and
eat chocolate an insane take it's it is
utterly uh absolutely bananas and
frankly to put your even if you make you
have some like
rational uh connection you've made in
your mind it's not worth putting your
neck out for that one brother like let's
keep that one locked up in the chamber
we don't need to give pedos any green
lights insane I'm so confused by people
in shat we have had so many people in sh
like you don't know the full context
we'll watch it oh don't worry we have
the long yeah I know but the funny part
is that sure it's slightly different but
it's still so bad it's funny because
like in this part particular probably
round up uh some people today if you
know what I'm saying right right
Honeypot here's um Honeypot in our own
chat it's funny cuz people go oh he's
taken out of context but listen what he
says assistant yes 100% listen very
carefully to the exact language that I
use listen very carefully as I express
myself articulately and clearly as I
possibly can have yet to hear a
convincing moral or legal argument as to
why possession of child pornography
should be illegal AR wait how what what
does he mean by that like so so first of
all the making of it is a crime the yeah
a horrific crime one of the worst
probably one of the worst crimes you can
commit how does somebody get to the
point of possessing this content can
must be illegal the problem is I think
what he's saying is if you have it
you're not hurting anyone but what you
are doing is you are you are and demand
exactly you're creating a demand for a
product he talks about all of this okay
let's watch it well I'll wait then I'll
wait if you want to get into it just go
to we have this full clip like not in
the compilation let me watch the
compilation I'm not going to pause it
then you should go through one by one
cuz a lot of what you're asking is is
okay good I was making and I've made
this argument a bunch of times and I've
addressed this poorly made argument a
bunch of times here why is the
possession of child pornography immoral
people are incon consistent in their
moral outrage at Commodities which hurt
people when they're produced so people
are you are you calling child
pornography a
commodity is that traded on
Forex what's the going rate on child
pornography on the S&P right now the
[__] will laugh off cocoa butter or
chocolate or um you know or or Cobalt or
other you know products that we tend to
get through a really really unethical
those those things can be produced
ethically mhm child pornography
cannot and also I don't think people
necessarily
know that it is made unethically I've
only learned about that recently when
we're talking about chocolate well your
your your influence on that is extremely
limited like iPhones they get cobalt you
don't know where the [__] they're
getting their their rare Min Earth
minerals from and you just go and buy a
phone it's like you're you have a
limited control over that and it's
something that people do try actively to
not um allow to happen it's not like
people are like oh yeah let's have child
I'm looking I want Cobalt that was made
by child slaves yeah which is
what consumers of the CP do but frankly
um again you can do all those things
ethically and hopefully we're we're
walking towards a world in which Cobalt
and cocoa butter and chocolate and
coffee and all that [__] is made
ethically however we will never live in
a world where child pornography can be
made ethically and the thought of it is
absolutely obscene like don't even you
know what I mean like [__] me dud system
but then they're really really quick to
denounce child now you'll never be able
to find a clip of me saying that I think
it's good to have child porn should
consuming child porn be legal yes 100%
please please right now uncuck your dumb
[__] libcuck [__] sjw brains and
recognize this empirically correct fact
that I am about once again he sets it up
in the clearest terms possible list
clear your ears out everybody sit down
and listen to every word which I mean
with my whole body and soul SP it
is for an adult and a child to have a
sexual relationship and for it to have
positive outcomes on the child as well
that's game I don't know how he survived
that one what how I don't know how he
survived that
one that sentence should not be said no
matter what the context is there more
context to that one yeah there is it is
that we have that clip as well
phenomenal I honestly think cuz I'm so
can't wait I think it's a mistake to be
watching these clips because we're
giving an opportunity to be like oh
you're not understanding the full
context we are going to we're going to
get the whole context don't say you
can't say that that's not fair we're
going to watch them all but we're almost
the compilation okay Bosch gets kicked
off of platforms for saying cracker but
not for saying pedophilia can be good
for children quot can here I'll ask you
just follow through I'm not an idealist
I'm not going to talk about
hypotheticals that don't have any
bearing on material reality I'm not
going to talk about hypothetical
situations where adults can molest
children and it has a positive outcome
not something I'm going to talk about
you're the one hold on wait hold on
first of all I don't know why you want
here's a comment from his Discord which
I'm assuming is real I I don't know but
it says the way I see at the age of
consent exists out of respect for the
numerous power imbalances older people
have over younger people as those
imbalances or at least some of them are
redressed through the Advent of
socialism the age of consent should
therefore be lowered I knew it was
socialism that was doing this to
people I don't uh I don't uh endorse
this uh what does socialism have to do
with agent consent that's crazy I he's
on some [__] libertarian brain dude I
don't know what to say dude
whoa talk about
so imagine all right imagine aliens come
down to earth this is absolutely
ridiculous Vos yeah okay so okay granted
a lot of those were not the full context
and it's fair to set it up that way
because online a lot of people that see
those only see those so today we give
you that and now we give you the full
thing okay also real quick to give uh
ownership the the person who made that
was YouTube police department on Twitter
thanks buddy nice thank
you did you say that I had said that
okay you know what no I swear to God I
swear to God I just got from the
bathroom and I just had this thought
let's put a monitor in the bathroom no
I'm so serious not a bad idea that's a
good idea has happened any hold I I
actually went number two on the bathroom
I I bring my monitor watch but it's
delayed it's delayed though so I'm
missing so we we actually just bought
some new monitor speakers and and had
the thought to uh put them out there I I
like the idea One Step yeah I'm thinking
that if you don't say it you're going to
get [__] so I'm just trying to cover
otherwise I would send it in chat even
though I did that last time you still
read it out loud
but we have the the XLR run so all we
just got to do is plug it in you know
what I think that's a good idea though I
really like like when we do live shows
how they have like speakers everywhere
on the same thing yeah good okay we'll
get on that I should we I guess this is
one that Dan introduced me to that I
think is good to set the tone the Tacoma
wept one now Dan shared this all right
just a little back like
listen I don't want to get into it too
much but I will
say that this was probably the first
clip I ever saw of
vou and it was the last it it should
have been the last clip that I Ever Saw
V it it pretty much turned me off to
ever
so here here he is um somebody says he
can't get laid and he gets defensive
about that why is it so small I know
there's I don't know it's a weird
Twitter forting thing Jesus Christ you
get the
idea wait is this guy seriously saying
that I can't get laid incredible I'll
give you 5,000 if you can get punon Tang
before January 1st do you have any idea
who the [__] you're talking
to when I got off T when I got off
Tinder because the [__] quarantine
Tacoma
wept brother even like ignoring the fact
that I have a girlfriend even if we're
just talking like randos I'm two hours
away right now from being inside
somebody else this is one I I have two
skills and it's non monogamy and
speaking publicly okay do some [__]
research what [__] do some
research anytime anything huge happens
we have to say to Taca
we that's definitely so wait is Tacoma
wept a reference or is that where you
live no I think it's yeah so he's
genuinely like how have we never watched
this I've seen it from Dan yeah I don't
wept is my brain forever a lot of people
in our audience like this guy and so
we've always just kind of purposely
steered clear but I've had that one in
the back pocket for years and behind the
scenes I've I've referenced Tacoma wept
I'm going to comment that on your next
Instagram post
I think it's honestly a phenomenal
versatile it sounds incredible it has a
I mean he's right though he has a he
clearly has a knack for public
speaking one of his two best strengths
so Tacoma web you have it Zach uh I'll
pull but also is this so gross how he
goes I'm two hours away from being
inside of somebody else disgusting like
with or without permission what do you
mean with permission with permission
okay well he didn't wasn't clear about
it it made it sound like I'm coming
inside you he's hot [__] give me two
hours Tacoma we two hours in a bottle of
ethery right forgive me I I still don't
get it the Tacoma we oh so he says
because when I got off of
Tinder my entire the entire city of
Tacoma where he lives people were crying
okay it was just so devastating that he
wasn't on got it got it got it got it
got it Tacoma wept got
it he's he's good at two
things public speaking and [__] baby
and he and he's all out of words and
look it up if you don't believe it and
if I run out of people and I'm all out
of people to [__] where is the next Farm
I want to hear Tacoma wept again yeah
where's I'm 2 hours from the nearest
farm that's so funny oh my God off
Tinder because the [__] even if
you're a fan you got to admit this
shit's kind of funny you got to be
giggling if you're a fan of as but I
listen I won't judge you if you keep
watching them but I will be perpetually
uh shocked that people are watching one
of our Chatters says I live in Tacoma
I'm sorry for your
loss quarantine Tacoma wept idea who the
[__] you're talking
to when I got off T when I got off
Tinder because the [__] quarantine
Tacoma
wept
that's a lot so that so that's just to
set the tone Tacoma
wept should we so let's get into the the
the main sources here so this one Vos
explains the context of the quote I am
yet to hear a convincing moral or legal
argument as to why
CP should be illegal so here is the full
clip for our consideration real quick I
have the the sound bite now go ahead a
blizzard woy for that one Tacoma
wept
try it is tragic you there's dude this
whole thing is sound bite like the
fertile the fertile
Valley we got to pull all kinds from
this yeah also when he says like what
what was it look it up or research it do
your research do your research on all on
my sexual
Conquest all right here here he is
describing it and by the way I love this
game dead cells great game so far yeah
shout out yeah Tacoma we you're
convincing moral or legal argument as to
why possession of child pornography
should be
illegal now that one wow wait one second
that's
a trying to figure out where Ian has the
uh the other box the other pip Tacoma
wept I know where it is I
just where's the PIP Ian where's the PIP
where's the other pip I where's the PIP
in where's the PIP in here I got it I'll
just move it
Chad said I'm ignoring when you say
something it gets you back for never
hearing
[Music]
me huh yeah what I'm just kidding I'm
just
kidding oh you're you're trying to get
revenge by doing that that's what Chad
said you it's pretty funny I mean keep
doing it okay go ahead like three or
four times today it's really some
amazing I mean it's funny now I I don't
have to call it out I just go thanks
dude everybody knows it's fun we love it
we love it we love these things all
right go ahead justify explain a Zinger
isn't it I have yet to hear one
convincing argument yeah I saw hyena uh
I have yet to hear one convincing
argument for why child pornography
should be illegal I know W now what the
context that's missing here is that when
I was saying that I was
saying in the world we live in right
now I don't think there's a conv vincing
moral or legal argument which is
consistent with the morals or legality
that we currently have now what does
that mean well the argument that I was
making and I've made this argument a
bunch of times and I've addressed this
poorly made argument a bunch of times
here on this stream is that well let's
go through the logic why is the
possession of child pornography immoral
because it hurts people to make child
pornography yeah because you have to
hurt children to make it that's why it's
immoral it's not magically immoral it's
immoral because of the harm that is
caused bu it so do we not possess other
things that you sound like someone who's
trying to rationalize child abuse like
that is an insane that's
actually it's like okay this is wrong
that is not better this is wrong but
there's also other stuff that are wrong
this is ration rationalizing people who
do horrible [__] they rationalize it in
their mind so they can live with it this
man says you eat chocolate and you dare
to care about child pornography that's
that's what his point is right I can't
stop looking at his shirt that says
adult only like why it's like his own
version of girl math unless it's the
hentai I'm downloading that's boy math
you were asking earlier oh yeah that's
the boy math you were talking about go
ahead go ahead Vos let's follow the
logic as you said say for example the
innumerable Supply chains which hurt
other people the child slavery what have
you um the argument that I was making
essentially is that people are
inconsistent in their moral outrage at
Commodities which hurt people when
they're produced so people will laugh
off cocoa butter or chocolate or um you
know or or Cobalt or other you know
products that we tend to get through a
really really unethical system but then
they're really really quick to denounce
child porn now you'll never be able
that's not a problem as you should be
yeah that's not a problem you should be
really quick to even if there's some can
you fault them cuz like one is very easy
to understand one is the wrong thing is
right in front of you nois needed the
other one you need to know and you need
to do research and you need to learn
that it's behind the scenes it's being
made wrongly yeah you it's not easy to
piece all that together MH does it
surprise you that people care about CP
more than they care about Cobalt farming
I mean it shouldn't absolutely shouldn't
we all have children we don't I don't
have a Cobalt mine in my backyard I
don't know what the [__] that's like
just being real um that's crazy that's
crazy I don't like that I also think
your point that you already made earlier
about you could figure out a way to make
those things ethically you cannot figure
out it's not the same a way to make
child pornography is not a commodity
it's not it's it's it's something else
it's this isn't wheat and [__] Cobalt
and [__] that's traded shipped on boats
and traded internationally this is
something else putting it in the same
bracket as that is truly just a
rationalization I mean in the worst
possible way it's actually really [__]
up to find a clip of me saying that I
think it's good to have child born or
that it's okay to hurt children or
anything like that because those were
never the arguments that I was making it
was only an indication oh my God it's
just like every other clip of you quote
unquote defending CP yep it's just like
the other 47 times this has happened now
that doesn't seem like an exaggeration
why are you defending it 47 times I
think he's kidding he's kidding or is he
not kidding well we've we already seen
in the Highlight kind of true cuz there
are a lot of Clips so just from what
we've seen in that highlight clip holy
[__] I'm sorry 20 minutes from Tacoma
there's this famous case of a guy died
um from injury sustained while
attempting to have sex with a
Horsea
wept we lost a good one that day Tinder
wept what was he trying to which was he
on top or on bottom say you think it
says that uh engaging in receptive anal
intercourse with the horse yeah he dude
he was getting railed by a horse and oh
my God oh my God I guess there was
multiple guys it was labeled by the
internet two guys one horse do you think
he knew them Vos was might have been
there oh my
God that's why Taca wept cuz he died
yeah wait that's the Mr hands yeah Z
that's what you were saying the Mr okay
cuz you were saying Mr hands I'm like
who the hell is that you're right Mr
hands Zack brought up to me he's like
it's like Mr hands and I was like I
don't know what that is but that's the
case they they went under the Alias Mr
hands um W I don't know I don't know the
horse [__] okay Brad in the chat
here um so just wrote I'm Hot Tacoma
weest it's like Brad I want to [__] me
right now that means put on the AC
please thank you Legend so so that was a
bit
nasty we love you we need fit's back on
the show yeah everybody misses him like
he he won everybody over wow it was
really actually phenomenal dude he's in
like the European Parliament or some
[__] right now I've been following his
story oh yeah what is he doing yeah he
took a flight some to somewhere and he's
hanging out with politicians from what
I've seen his story oh yeah he said he
was running for prison or something
cyress cuz he's the most famous
siyan we got dude can we set up a call
with him you want another one absolutely
everybody wants to hear don't know how
old he is you
know it's
interesting okay so Mr hands is like a
case that people know about yeah a lot
of people in chat seem to be familiar
why they call him Mr hands that was his
name online that okay okay okay was he
like a known horse [__] yeah he like
recorded a bunch of uh films I believe
oh boy were released after he died maybe
oh like uh that's awesome it's like
Tupac albums yeah yeah like like life
after death oh that's biggie he died for
what he
loves all right vosch go ahead um but so
here's what I'm getting from this his
original statement I have yet to hear a
moral or legal argument for why
possession of CP should be illegal let's
isolate that and compare comp it to what
he said was his explanation for saying
that and it doesn't really make sense
the comment he's saying his explanation
for justifying that comment doesn't
really make line up to me if you're
trying to say that people are morally
they're morally inconsistent with things
like Cobalt and chocolate and
coffee you would say that you wouldn't
say you could say that ability ion other
ways that would be way more effective
and as he said himself he has two skills
one is you know uh being a public
speaker and the other one is non-
monogamy and horses involved in that
apparently uh Partners is could be a man
woman Ora in his
case Centaur like cre somewhere in
between but but my point is this guy's
smart and he's a good communicator so
mhm like him
saying does that even speak to what he
said if he says I haven't heard a
convincing moral or legal argument for
why CP should be illegal does that in
any way actually address what he said
he's saying well I okay so the argument
is that you know under capitalism we
have all of these Commodities and Supply
chains that are part of our everyday
life and the acquisition of those things
it involves often times things that we
consider immoral either slave labor or
just massively underpaid labor or excuse
me
Dennis um and he's saying that if you
are okay this is his point if you're
okay with that then you don't really
have you're a hypocrite if you're not
okay with the CP stuff and if you were
trying to convey that would you say I
have never heard anyone give me a
convincing argument why CP should be
illegal or was even immoral right well I
think work that in what you said is is
the big gaping hole in my opinion of
what he and I'm not talking about Mr his
[__] after the horse yeah yeah uh
four for four four for four thanks bro I
think the B hole is that that one like
Cobalt chocolate like they're listen I
you know I agree that there are terrible
practices involved in the acquisition of
a lot of these things um but but at the
end of the day those are all Commodities
that have some utility to society and
you can still quibble about like oh is
us having chocolate as privileged
westerners is that you know make it okay
that we use slave labor and you know you
can denounce that there there is no
situation where the child pornography is
okay there there is like that doesn't
exist and so the comparison doesn't work
it
doesn't I frankly hearing him explain
the quote context makes me frankly I
don't believe him because it doesn't
make sense the two those two statements
are not logically connected because it's
more they're victims more than
Commodities I know he's trying to get
across I mean it doesn't make no [__]
sense but I don't believe him I don't
believe that that's what he meant even
the argument is just like so flimsy
because he then has to say that not the
act of making the child porn is immoral
but like you have to at a certain point
say that simply child porn if there
isn't a victim is
moral like that's well he well he does
come close to saying that when he says
he said previously which I guess there's
more context to that children and adults
can have meaningful healthy sexual
relationships and it could be positive
for the child so I believe the next clip
that we have is that another
justification for CP I mean it just by
the way let me just defend myself
everyone says oh Ethan I saw you sniff
your
finger oh boy there was a little thing
here I didn't know if it was a piece of
cake or a piece of cardboard so I
touched it and I smelled my fingers to
see it's cardboard by the way oh I'll
I'll defend you I've done things like
that yeah I don't know if that
helped so that's that uh let me keep
seeing if there's anything else here are
we going to watch um more context for
that statement cuz that one is wild
apparently yes okay I'm curious Tacoma
wept the point that I'm making here is
that I think that all of these things
are immoral see I don't think that
that's what you were
saying I mean you can disagree show me
the original clip I think the issue is
still in his explanation I don't think
the explan you're you're saying you just
don't believe him I don't believe him
because what he's saying doesn't make
sense the what he said I mean I don't
know does not connect to what he's let's
see the original clip I don't want to
see him trying to um explain it away
yeah here he is trying to rationalize it
let's see the original clip I want to
see that and then I'll have a better
idea of what he was actually saying at
the moment right and again this is a man
who touts one of his two skills in life
as being a public
speaker these things should be illegal
um and the reason why this uh
cancellation attempt comes up every
couple of months is because uh uh and
and by the way this never comes up in
person when people talk to me well okay
okay I guess it's F I guess it doesn't
matter everyone's a
coward I bet I dare you to call me a
pedophile to my
face it's because the people who make
these accusations about me know they
would get blown the [__] out oh drama
alerts in chat oh what does that mean
that you would fight them drama Alert in
chat is that what he meant that I will
fight you he he's a you know he's a he's
a debater he he wants to debate you
he's going to want to debate me on this
specifically I mean he's going to want
to debate me on this I'll take that I'll
do it he's the he's apparently the great
debater he fancies himself
as so what happens when um Chris Hansen
meets the I'm kidding I'm not Chris
Hansen what happens when the hay meets
the horse so no cookies for
you let's get to the bottom of it bucko
what was on the agenda tonight Keem you
want to come on we can talk about it ke
star here oh [__]
Godly that's a time that's my time to
exit so okay that's his now I don't know
I mean do people think that that con
that explanation is
convincing I mean I his his supporters
think so
yeah it's um I didn't find it
particularly compelling my problem is
that there's no logic there like doesn't
connect it doesn't connect and I and he
seems like a a smart guy so why would
that one be people want me to debate him
so weird do you think he's going to
debate me on whether or not he's whether
or not I'm yeah I guess he has nothing
to lose but that's pretty much what he
does in one of these clips well that's
kind of yeah there's one coming up where
he is doing exactly that so okay Vos if
you want to if you want to
debate well he hasn't said that we were
just he's going to want to I know it
he's the biggest debate Lord online I'm
sure in his opinion that's the only way
he can fix
this yeah I don't know that I kind of
with the other guy he's like I don't
even I don't want to argue if CP is bad
I don't want to even engage in that
conversation necessarily
right you know I don't you Cobalt and
[__] coffee and all that [__] it's
just a very weird argument to make like
even if what you're saying is true which
it's not I don't want to have the
conversation
mhm cuz there's going to be pedophiles
that are like yeah that explains why
everybody else is a hypocrite dud are
going to go home and [__] a kid and be
like everyone's a hypocrite how dare
they judge me yeah that's the world you
want to live in go eat your
chocolate everyone has their advice I
[__] kids you eat
chocolate I don't see the big
difference I mean dude you're going to
get dude there's no shot what's your
argument there's no [__] shot bro
what's your
argument it uh there that would be a
hell of a debate I mean I don't even
know how how to even get into that let's
see if he wants to I don't think about
it the topic for
today is Vos in support of pedophilia
and Zu
filia The Debaters Ethan
kin and
Vos the Bosch the horse Jackson I don't
know what his last name
is
when the and welcome everybody today's
episode of when the hay meets the horse
Tacoma wept Tacoma wept ladies and
gentlemen welcome wept
wept oh man all right so let's move on
then I guess
I guys monitor the chat if there's fans
of him that are saying I am missing
something please let me know uh here's
the next one context that of this is the
one you said Ela is it possible for a
child to have sexual Rel reltionship and
it be positive here's his explanation
for that
one look this is super duper simple okay
utilitarianism act
utilitarianism is about considering the
consequences of a specific action okay
bro why did you have to mix Zelda into
all this [__]
man how are we talking about utilit
reism he's really coming after Ocarina
time with this
conversation that means so much to so
many of us Majora's Mask oh that's
Majora's Mask my bad [__] I actually
started playing that recently oh I love
it me and Teddy were playing it for a
bit lost oh that's cute it's kind of
scary it's intense yeah it's it's a
weird one it's all about death it's hard
too a dark one super hard we have an
interesting update V uh addresses the
folder um just recently like 30 minutes
ago after we get through this I'll send
you okay we we'll Circle back breaking
update breaking update big news the ad
placement in ab's shot oh don't move it
oh look no I I hide this on
purpose all right go ahead vosch it is
possible please please right now uncuck
your dumb [__] libcuck [__] sjw
brains and recognize this empirically
correct fact that I am about to spit it
is
possible for an adult and a child to
have a sexual
relationship and for it to have positive
outcomes on the child as well that is
possible you know what you know what my
physicist says as possible I could fall
through the ground because our atams uh
lined up in the same wavelength somehow
I mean who gives a [__] no yeah I only
have one word no you think what are you
saying that like teenagers had sex with
adults in like ancient Greek and that
was fine or something like what is your
point that in some magical
world like what what's the point of this
argument this one is crazy my blood is
starting to B why are you why are you
saying
this blah boiling what point are you
trying to make all right go ahead
BOS however categorically no don't
however it's not discourage those
relationships because as a rule it is
subst he's sweating bro he knows he
[__]
up he knows dude his career is flashing
before his eyes he said to too
much anally more likely that enabling
them would cause harm in society raw
that's the difference between raw wait
let me let me go he yeah let me go back
I'm hear this he's look scared ra he
looks like Chris Hansen about to come in
that
door and for it to have positive
outcomes on the child dude his shirt why
is he always got to have the wildest
shirt raw yeah yeah raw dude you take a
she right over there yeah the shirts
really don't help his whole argument so
far the r the other one with the only
that is
possible however
categorically we discourage those
relationships because as a rule it is
substantially more likely that enabling
them would cause harm in society okay so
why what is the point of like no susing
this out exactly no no you're saying in
no cases is this possible I'm saying
this is the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
It's upsetting really upsetting but
there's just no point to have why have
this conversation what is he saying that
maybe there's one case where it didn't
traumatize the kid show me that one case
first of all but so what so maybe
there's one so then we're all Hypocrites
because well he's saying he's saying
what on the whole it's more likely to
negatively affect kids and therefore as
a whole we view it as a bad thing even
though sometimes in some cases it's a
good thing no no I say no yeah and also
show me who are you talking about what
is this you got some dat on that and why
I meaness why is this the conversation
you want to have I don't that's my
question about the first and the clip
too yes like the first question be like
okay shut up why this isn't like a
pertinent philosophical
question that needs to be thought
through this is like
disgusting perversion dude this this
this is like a man what I see is someone
rationalizing the
consumption of child pornography frankly
that's what I'm seeing and so maybe it
seem feels pertinent to you and again I
don't know what kind of pornography
you're well I do actually based on but
not all of it I don't know what else is
in that folder if you scroll down a lot
folders but this is a guy who seems
eager to rationalize the
consumption of CP on both
accounts oh we have a Vos fan in chat
all right what what am I missing Vos
said that CP is just as bad as child
slavery if you're okay with slavery bit
you have to be okay with CP which is
objectively true that's ridiculous we
all understood that was the point he was
making that's a bad still a ridiculous
Point first of all nobody said they're
okay with slavery
second of all we said that that one can
be more complicated first of all to know
that it's happening but also there are
things to do about avoiding it and I
think companies are constantly working
on that and the point is the other one
is just bad in all cases exactly you can
make coffee ethically it's not inherent
to it if you if you're going and buying
an iPhone and there's some unethical
Cobalt in it nobody's going to [__]
know that but if you're sitting down to
watch CP guess what I got no questions
right there's no questions left right
right there's none it's a weird point I
don't care what y'all how much y'all
love him it's a weird ass point to
make whether he's right or wrong it's
[__] weird oh he TW he tweeted me yo
H3 wants to talk that's totally cool but
you'll have to wait a sec cuz I'm
getting a haircut right now you're M
you're getting your main
trimmed
bro you want me to not today not right
now we're almost out of time let's chew
on hours Let's chew on this like some
fresh ha or carrots or something peanut
butter bowl it over apple slices apple
slices I hear horses love I hear that
too you know like colon Costco I
appreciate it because but but at the
same time it's weird there's no need for
this conversation to take place not only
there's no need it actually is most
likely probably harmful always so why
are you even having this conversation
that's my point what are you trying to
do right now what kind of audience are
you looking to get
yeah what type of people people from
Tacoma oh God stay away from Tacoma
Tacoma no it's Washington no disrespect
to the tacom yeah no disrespect what's
the population there Tac find out
someone had a suggestion that maybe
Tacomo is the name of a
horse okay
that's come on it's a
220,000 that's that's not a lot so we
can write them all off yeah [__] them we
can write them all off Tacoma you're
done yeah Tacoma wept all right go on
vosch explain in your sweaty stressed
out
State you know [__] up raw raw Dogg
it that's the difference between act and
Rule
utilitarianism an act utilitarian would
say oh this is an instance where it was
good for the adult and the minor to have
sex that would make it a good action but
the rule utilitarian how do you measure
that bro how who's setting up to measure
that yeah I'm really
curious you know
dude You' and it's not not just once
you've done this several times like a
point he keeps coming back
to I am would say even though that
individual outcome was good the Act was
still bad because in general in a
broader application for adults and
children to have sex with one another
leads to he's like if Plato met Jimmy
sevel well or just Plato met Plato oh
yeah you know what I'm yeah true what if
you yeah there you go you know no we're
not thinking about this I was thinking
cuz I I don't I have no idea if he's a
philosophy major or whatever but you
know it there's a bit of a reputation
with
the these types Phil philosophers yeah
they there's a whole thing about
philosophers [__] kids like anti
antiqua
H more modern times too I don't know I
didn't know
that well I mean it's kind of a a Trope
almost of like the philosophy professor
at a school sleeping with his students
like that that that's kind of like I
didn't know that that's kind of like a
story Trope I can't speak to how common
that actually is in real life but that's
definitely a thing Vos is daring to put
forward this very bold and cunning and
objectively true statement if you think
CP is bad you just haven't thought about
it
enough and I will continue to think
about it as much and more than everybody
and to talk about it more than
everybody horribly destructive outcomes
for that reason it is an unethical act
so on the off chance it might help
someone we we just allow everyone to
engage in a generally destructive
practice except that's the literal exact
opposite of what I am saying do you
[__] brain worms
by fairy 79 I literally made the
opposite of that point I literally just
explained the opposite of what you just
said that no just because in the off
chance it might help someone who
shouldn't categorically support one
action because I am a rule utilitarian
but what is the one why do you guys keep
doing this because what are you because
what do you keep doing this yes why is
your argument is so dumb just don't
argue just don't touch this stuff man
this is not a case where there could be
one that was good there
no yeah let's several
many what's your argument people some
people's brains just turn off hyena you
did this too but their mind what's with
people they just get emotional when I
talk about child
porn can you all just sit chill
out my man sounds like he's trying Tock
link what just weird I feel like talking
about this while his uh playing a kid
character in the game I don't know it's
a little weird oh no true H rule wept
put that controller down Man true stop
controlling that child uh it's actually
uh uh [__] I was going to out nerd you
but I can't remember the name of the
world from mandor's maskk terminal
Terminus termina termina yeah okay that
was close with Mega Man yeah I grew up
with Mega Man n from the beginning
perfectly understandable from the h
go how do you think minor should be
defined I don't know age of consent
memes are really [__] complim
complicated shouldn't like bro this it's
not a good onew combo consent memes it's
not a good onew combo memes or I miss
pow hit him with the CP is is good in
some cases pow hit him with the age of
consent laws
complicated that onew punch you's got a
killer jab as I like to quote my good
friend love what is bro Yapp about dude
what
[Laughter]
is I think I keep thinking this could
conceivably be all right in Fringe cases
just feel like a useless argument yes I
agree because I'm a rule utilitarian all
right bro whatever I'm a I'm a Ral
utilitarian too and when I hear people
here's my rule not all the times people
are defending CP are they creeps but
it's enough times that they're doing it
that they're creeps but on the whole
it's a bad thing to do interesting
interesting an interesting rule the same
logic bro that's why I will not be uh
you are a creep and that's and that's
just utilitarian logic or whatever you
it's interest it is and then so there's
another one can we just say too before
we continue that like to just cut off
some criticisms or whatever is like even
if you you're you're comfortable you
know debating these uncomfortable Topics
in in the in terms of philosophy or
whatever um is
there is there a reason that it that
this is like the go-to argument you know
what I mean like there's so many of
these clips and it's like was there not
a better way to make these philosophical
points thought comparing things to child
pornography all the time well there's
not a lot of good ones to begin with so
no they like that's that's it well I
mean what what else you going to say
about it that's good about it uh if you
know it it's good for the
economy
uh no I just even mean like in the sense
of like he's making this utilitarian
argument of you know is there is there
not a less extreme example and I guess
this is just the the one time but it's
the cons it's the coming up in lots of
Clips thing that Cru economy
out becomes a pattern that's what I'm
saying man it the economy you know how
much those shipping uh containers cost
man when you do human trafficking and
those that there's a lot of there's a
lot of business and industry there dude
hurts
nobody
right uh here's one more another clip of
Vos Vos no wait hold on here he is
defending uh again another pedo quote
GRE there I I don't think there's any
situation where an adult can have a
child a sexual relationship with a child
and it has a positive outcome so we do
actually seen the full bit that was C
from so no no no no no no BOS we just
watched it you gave that as a scenario
that was one of the scenarios wasn't it
he literally said there are no actually
okay what he said is it's possible yeah
but I mean we going to split hairs on
that if it's possible then you're saying
no you're saying it can happen it's
possible it's possible an adult in a
child can have a a good healthy sexual
relationship that's what you said then
you would agree you saw the full bit not
just the Twitter bit I saw it all but
the full thing yeah your logical
Foundation was that there can be some
situations where an adult and a child
can have a positive outcomes you didn't
say anyway it's totally
immaterial just well no it's it's it's
important so in
[Laughter]
a no no no I want to talk about this
well this is my favorite topic so let's
yeah
as one of the great orators of our time
I've fully prepared myself to discuss
the topic and he always buries
himself imagine that that's now that you
know if you're trying to brush up on
your debating chops you know someone
takes the opposing side someone takes
the supporting side if you're trying to
test your chops I guess supporting child
pornography is probably like s tier
difficulty terms of the debate platform
so maybe that's what he's doing he's
just trying to sharpen his his
tools consequentialist sense you can
easily construct a situation where
essentially anything is f can here I'll
ask you just follow through 30 seconds
I'm not an idealist I'm not going to
talk about hypotheticals that don't have
any bearing on material reality that is
wait wait hold on he's like listen I
don't want to sit here while you
describe a hypothetical situation where
a child enjoyed having sex with an adult
let's not have that conversation and
he's like no no no no this is important
not going to do that I'm not going to
talk aboute with I'm not going to talk
about hypothetical situations where
adults can molest children and has a
posit talk you're the one wait hold on
wait Zach you're doing it today bud no
you're doing it you're doing it brother
you're doing you're doing it you you are
doing it today my friend no you man
[__] wait hold on first of all you want
to talk about
this wait no hold on wait you can't you
can't move away from this okay hold on
I'm
not you can't move away from
this that's what the kids says but
apparently no you like it I promise see
that's [__] up to even joke about I
wouldn't joke about that should I button
it no should I Buton itbe next time no
you're criticizing yeah you're
fine
no I'm not I can't
disc you have to stop talking for one
second okay hold on so imagine all right
imagine aliens this [__] says
it's
possible and then he started with
imagine aliens imagine time is
completely uh liquidated and age means
nothing right okay so here's the thing
imagine the time is the fourth dimension
and and we and if you're living in the
fourth dimension you view everybody in
every moment of their of their life so
if you're having sex with an 8-year-old
you're really having sex with a
30-year-old 40y old 50-year-old when
you're having sex with a 50-year-old
you're having sex with an 8-year-old at
the same time it's just we don't see all
the dimensions at
once imagine the movie ET you know how
his finger could heal stuff imagine
Elliott has ass
cancer
oh I'm trying to think of a situation
imagine okay wait you you got me buddy
that's maybe that's where he's going
maybe he said alien let's see I don't
know where the [__] he's going with this
come down to earth this is absolutely
ridiculous V you youve bled imagine
aliens this is as hypothetical idealism
as you can get you're totally you're L
you're in outer space you're actually
literally in outer space imagine a
benevolent Predator pedophile from space
lands on
earth like you're you're like a
honeymoon virgin you got last longer
than 6 seconds just give me a second and
again no sex jokes not now yeah not not
stay away stay away
BOS let's keep our heads on straight now
let's talk about the aliens okay I let
you did I not let you talk for a long
time when you were establishing your
premises I'm not going to talk about
hypothetical with you I let you talk for
a long time now let me explain why child
for this
crazy I mean this guy is absolutely in
the right for not of course of course
it's crazy it is how did he survive all
this I
wonder he has a bunch of fans that will
defend it to the end I
like listen if you were a fan of vouches
or are whatever
and you defend this just like in the
sense that like he's just using extreme
hypotheticals in order to you know uh
for the sake of the argument and none of
this is real you know if this has any uh
real impact on his own views he's just
using it as an example how do you square
that with the dude having a folder full
of Lolli porn like doesn't that change
the context at all for you seeing all
this it should it should right cuz he
would he app been joking about loving
horse CS for a long time people thought
he was kidding or didn't know if he was
being serious but now we know we've seen
the horse coocks and we've seen the LLY
right like 3 days ago before that
happened You' maybe have leg to stand on
with the argument of like he believe all
this you know maybe it's in bad taste
but these are valid uh you know these
are arguments that are being made for
demonstrative purposes but now the dude
has a folder full of lonly porn I I
don't know that kind of changes the
context the pieces are coming together
doesn't it I think it does a little bit
sure socialism thank you Camden he says
socialism is when no age of
consent that's that's what I'm saying
dude
right social democracy is the only
way you don't have to you just have to
listen you just have to listen okay now
you can imagine a situation in which
aliens come down to earth and they say
we're going to blow up the whole planet
unless you kill this innocent kid now in
a dude you are not serious you losing me
this is your best [__]
consequentialist sense killing that
innocent I know right so follow through
I know it's horrible so
consequential so in a consequential I
know an inability to grasp philosophy is
one of my biggest
issues apply to both it's ideal absurd
it's
absurdism it's a comedy of of erors
or I don't even know if it's air what do
you call forced air I don't know it's
not not what I this philosophy and
idealism aren't the same thing those
don't mean the same you're basing your
you're constructing hypothetical
situations that have no bearing in
reality what hypotheticals aren't IDE
wait do you think an idealism is when
you construct a hypothetical
wait what's happening
here um did a crime is this ethical or
not just just tell me this was this an
ethical encounter yes or no why does it
look so real the
agenda maybe that's why ET left his
Planet maybe he was wanted for something
he's got a little poop on his finger
still well that doesn't mean anything
really so no cookies for you this is
edit by the way this is edited vosch was
not but ET is a pedophile was ET there
was definitely
there he got exiled from the
planet so I'm saying this was an ethic
iCal encounter ET equestrian terrestrial
dude cool do you think those mean the
same thing you're going to lecture me
point in having this discussion is my
point can you answer that question do
you think idealism means when you
construct a hypothetical if you
construct a hypothetical that has
nothing to do with reality and you think
that that gets you closer to the truth
that is idealism because you are find
you are making the ideal so anyway I'm
with him I'm with this guy guy damn
imagine getting online and saying some
of this
[__] grandpa is feeling a little frisky
today that's putting it
mildly wait people people are accusing
is this do people think this is a
conspiracy this just a Bouch fan oh God
you guys I'm sorry but like even as a
fan you have to admit that this is
pretty hit piece for a reason did they
do this hit piece for a reason what the
reason was that his folder leak was
extremely funny it shocked the hell out
of all of us this man is watching horse
yeah uh let's see what they say the clip
farming on today's show in regards to
Vos really shows how disingenuous he be
[__] we showing the whole last
clip I understand the argument I still
disagree you know it's not like I didn't
understand the sad part is when you
understand what he wants people to think
he's saying it's just as bad yeah it
doesn't actually help at all the
argument was about ethics not
CP maybe Ethan should look into how much
Vos took his side in the whole hisan
thing I don't give a [__] about
that what that's such a weird you ow him
bro yeah you owe him big time wait what
is he saying if aash took his side in
the whole Hassan thing before he started
pedo jacketing him I don't what Hassan
thing what what side it's it's the same
thing all these guys who hate Hassan say
like Evan preach when they were like oh
Ethan's acting this because he realized
after him and H son stopped talking
they're just you know what's interesting
though I will say cuz I've started
following this world that I didn't know
anything about but like I was saying
there's three main guys there's Vos
Destiny and Assan and they all [__]
hate each other they're all social or no
Destiny is not a socialist but they're
all like Libs and they all [__] hate
each other that doesn't bode well for
our the
left it's the most thing that there
could possibly be there zero
solidarity zero solidarity that is left
to a and the thing is I think
fortunately Hassan and Vos have like
very similar politics and yet they both
[__] hate each other very interesting
yeah they hate each other too I I honest
I think it's everybody hates each other
from what I can tell it's all I really
yeah I've I've it's interesting stayed
willfully ignorant of of Bou for mon
yeah I don't need anyone to defend me
against H I want the [__] what the the
[__] bro you're saying cuz he and even
if like that's true let's say I'm
grateful that he defended me against
Hanan that I'm like yo just cuz this guy
is a kind of
like defending child pornography he was
nice to me that one time so I'm going to
let it slide it's funny though that's
why there's reason why I want to talk
about it the [__] horse you got horse
F his porn
fter the funny thing is
that uh people would be calling you a
hypocrite if this is how you actually
went on would life like oh somebody said
something nice about me so I should um
King shaming now you're not serious are
you dude I I can't tell who's serious or
not anymore uh let's see maybe eth
should look into how much Vos defended
him he never even clarified that it was
drawn porn we did say that didn't we we
said there was no real horse images we'
said that a lot yeah let alone we're
into King shaming now this is not real
Jesus no
I think it is I've seen so he has a
community of of pedophiles Jr I guess I
guess that's why they're okay with
it we're talking about the I'm assuming
we're talking about the horse thing not
the kid thing no no like I said I am not
going to be a part of this Movement we
have to put the tolerance level
somewhere okay Ethan I found a uh like a
high somebody on Twitter found like the
highres versions of all those images
yeah it's disgusting dude I got to I got
to link it to you don't don't show the
on stream oh you found okay yeah let me
see from what I saw it was horrifically
[__] disgusting all right don't make
sure you don't show this up don't even
put it on the screen like just I'm
opening it open yeah just cuz the
reflection on
the I just clicked it didn't open I I
just
clicked doesn't make it any no I I put
on screen I didn't put on screen all
right it didn't show anything it didn't
it didn't show anything anyway but the
fact that this is drawn oh oh my God
these are the images they found found
them all oh oh it's even worse than I
thought yeah holy [__] okay whoa these
people are psycho how they figured all
this
out that's the these are these are these
are children like this photo here of
like the these are little girls anime
but they look really young they're all
drawings look at this one this one it's
like Snow White it's like busty young
looking Snow
White so bad dude yeah with
a look at this
heila I see okay maybe what's your we
get the
idea yeah you're right Cam that actually
puts it into context for me I mean
that's [__] that's nuts bro show
us yeah
well I got the horses in the
back [__] yeah no oh we have an edit
that uses that
song so yeah dude I'm sorry man but like
you kind of sound like a pedos
sympathizer in this post this is not
Kink we're not Kink shaming okay it's
weird bro we got to put we got to draw
the line in the
sand or in the
hay they've been beasts of Burden for
their so long man let's not start
[__] them now
[Laughter]
haven't they had enough let them live
haven't the horses had enough yikes
yikes also you think a horse wants to
[__] a person they could [__] another
hot ass horse yeah a ponia WEP like I'm
sorry
bro the horse doesn't want to [__] you
bro we it's time to move on that horse
does not want to [__] you we also using
clips from four or five years ago is
slimy when he's addressed this countless
times let alone cutting off before he
finish his argument I'm glad that I can
separate the brand these two own from
their uninformed opinion don't separate
the brand you can go do your pedo [__]
with your buddy I mean I don't want to
be rude but this is [__] weird I
don't want to be rude SE biscuit
wet C SE soggy biscuit SE soggy biscuit
SEC secretary WEP oh boy listen I but
here's what I take CR we showed the all
the contexts I didn't cut them off
everything you're saying I showed it all
we we very intentional about this we
said they were drawings I just looked at
at some internet researcher figured them
out and those images are truly truly
vile truly
vile
wept those are like children below 10
years old that's the descrition yeah how
can anyone argue against that in my
opinion that's straight up that's word
if you watch that kind of stuff and my
in my there is like an there is an
ethical conversation that goes on in
Japan they say if we make hent La hentai
and there are child predators in society
is it better for them to consume that if
it lowers the frequency of them harming
actual children and so there's a
philosoph do we know that it would lower
that I don't think I don't know I don't
know I mean have there has anybody
actually like studied if that's
effective idea I don't know but I've I
know that's a conversation that takes
place in Japan because in Japan a lot of
people
[__] I'd be curious if it also works the
other way around where it's like a entry
level thing and then it grows into like
this weird [__] like right AB you
normalize it you make people feel that
that it's okay next level Next Level we
know this about drugs we know that's
about about any human Obsession true it
always
increases true so I don't know dude but
yeah this stuff's completely legal in
Japan and like widely consumed
apparently I've heard I don't know I
might be speaking that term but I'm
pretty sure that's
true
um so there's actually the Tacoma web we
watch here's a compilation of all the
times vosch talked about horsecock on
his Discord somebody made this
compilation okay we've kind of missed
this element of this whole story so far
we haven't really like focused in on
this but the whole thing with the horse
I've discovered is that it's been a
thing for years sort of like a joke that
like oh Vos [__] horses or he's into
horses or whatever so the fact that they
then came out that he had a folder full
of horse
porn like this is crazy like this is a
post from three years ago with a
compilation of this dude talking about a
horsecock I got to mute the audio on
this I'm talking by the way AB I'm
talking about art not actual right okay
not actual you know without real
children in it in Japan I'm saying
that's popular not
CP um okay so here is this compilation
uh from dramatic text I I'm sorry I
meant to send the second paragraph as
well which was about like manga an
artist um this is social age of consent
sorry here let why is it copying the
whole damn thing just the bottom
one yeah manga artists and Anime
directors have argued that it is
dangerous to tried to Define child p
word when it comes to artwork drawings
and animations when regarding hentai due
to it being highly
[Music]
ambiguous not that much gray area and
have cited freedom of expression to
prevent it from being abused for for
example they are that even in the anime
and manga series doramon the scene of
the school girl Shia shaku minamoto
taking a bath might be construed as
child pornography listen if someone's
watching uh a lot of anime
they're [__] crazy yeah and a lot of
that [__] is kind of [__] disturbing
in that way so so you kind of hit the
nail on the head and frankly it's like
you said love there's like a lot of
borderline [__] vile weird sexual
stuff in anime and if anything it's
sending people right who are getting a
taste for that yeah there there are some
shows that I couldn't get into because
of that I like how they go dude you
could even call this scene child
pornography it's like we should yeah
exactly great Point even correct dragon
Dragon Ball which is like super vanilla
compared to a lot of other things like
when Goku was a kid he lifts up balma
skirt he's like touching her yeah he was
groping her Jesus W Goku uh art
depicting underage characters loyon and
shaon and photography of underage models
remain controversial dude photogra
photographs of underage models Junior
Idol Japan what's happening over there
this is the question of character what
is this character cam from the scene
that you were reading what you were just
talking about all right I'm
not yeah there's not necessary there's
some weird [__] going on and I think the
less of it the better globally anyway
here's V talking about horsecock delete
me from this conversation so it's
playing little NS right yeah you didn't
tell no that was another compilation
that was going around I found this one
cuz it was more direct it didn't have
like memes
let me read it to you what the [__] is
wrong with horsecock horse like it when
you slurp their balls I respect horse
[__] go i' love to have a horsecock
horsecocks are pretty hot to be honest
I'll tell them I'm down to meet up
tomorrow and they'll be like I can't
wait for you to destroy me with that
horse [__] and like and like [__] I'm
only 8 Ines bro you are a vile freak bro
you got to get a life outside
just think about horse Tacoma's weeping
right now
bro
H ecoin because I a I can't draw horses
well Dragon dildos are not as good as
horse dildo you know that feeling when
you're really why is he having these
like really explicit sexual
conversations with his fans too that's
kind of disturbing as well abolutely I'm
getting I'm getting sinjared
Vibes Ethan they says Ethan what age
would you let your kids start watching
anime I mean it depends on the
anime um
yeah like for example like Hunter Hunter
which is one of my favorite animes one
of the things that I love so much about
this show is they don't do any weird
sexual stuff there's the one character
know which one the one guy oh okay right
there is a pedophile in it yeah there's
always a master roosi but like I guess
what I mean what I mean is I forgot
about hisaka Jesus Christ dude no but
okay so in that in that show there's no
like weird cleavage young girl sexual
[__] like it doesn't it doesn't happen I
thought that was so refreshing there is
a character one who is very interesting
and he's attracted to
power and he he has like this weird
infatuation almost sensual in situation
with power and because these two boys
are so powerful it gets it it gets in
there really [__] weird thing so yeah
there is a weird thing here with Haka
although I got to say in terms of
dealing with the subject I thought it
was kind of interesting it's honestly
really annoying it's almost like in
everything there is some sort of
something inappropriate in in anime yeah
even one piece like when I started one
piece in the early Seasons uh what's the
what's the redhead girl's name a Nami
yeah she looked like oh yeah we talked
about a [__] normal character there
was no like cleavage she was just like
dressed normal normal girl now when I'm
on like season like 10 or something it's
like titties out [__] shorts high as
[__] same thing with um same thing with
Robin it's so intense and I just I hate
that man yeah you know ranking of Kings
is an awesome super uh whome one yeah
that one's great you guys are in same
sing but Attack on Titan does not have
and the women characters are all like
very empowered the strongest that show
is like asexual if anything it's like
really like nonsexual I have so much
respect for anime shows that don't go
there yeah it's really such a bomber cuz
some some shows can be so good and then
there's this one
character Brotherhood clears the bar
yeah that one is really uncomfortable I
don't recall there being any like weird
stuff in well there was this really hot
scene when the muscle guys take yeah of
course no you're right I think full
metal is a good is a good Contender like
that one I would watch with my
boys like Alchemist is a great one I'm
trying probably that's an
adult Full Metal Alchemist might be a
little scary for them but I don't think
there's anything inappropriate super uh
one punch man great yeah I don't think
there's anything inappropriate there no
that one is [__] good yeah yeah that
doesn't really have anything weird is
there any miak there's no Miyazaki
movies with Miaki ones are yeah those
are all wholesome although I don't
know me what was the tooro I mean vosch
had a completely different don't even
joke about tooro like
that I saw
talking really really inappropriate
absolutely
not so I don't know what age I don't
know it depends on the anime it depends
on how mature they are I don't know at
this moment we're not watching anime
no kabish mob pyo 100's good too
yeah I'm got you can read this obviously
I feel if I keep reading this I'm going
to get nuked I wish I had hor so many
there so many I mean I'll just let it
play you guys can these are all take it
in from
2018 all seem to be from 2018 but this
was made years ago again this is not a
new thing with the horses which is still
blowing my mind every comment you see is
about horse
[__] yeah and they just did a keyword
search for horse not horse c not even
horse
C it's still going guys a we still have
a good 10 seconds
left can I really but like I hate that
he's talking with his fans about this
[__] I don't like that at all man Ash
politics why is everything moving down
am I tripping the TV's dropping am I
tripping out yeah you're it's an optical
illusion cuz you were watching scrolling
I was about to catch that I thought
maybe cuz the earthquake it was falling
off the what you didn't see you never
had that experience before no did you
ever play um rock band or Guitar Hero I
used to always happen to be hardcore the
whole time scolling like that and when
you're done you look away and the whole
world is doing that oh my God that's the
first time that's the first time for me
in thear hero
Universe um so that's fun and then
there's one more sus clip of Vos saying
he wants to be a horse I don't know what
this one is but sounds funny trampled by
a horse yeah that's true that's that's
another correct point that I don't
understand the relevance I it's true I
don't want to get trampled by a horse
thank you yeah I want I want to run
other people over as a horse thank you
Vos you don't want to be trampled by a
horse what that I
interesting I here this is him talking
about it if you want
okay
here wait yeah
here here's DeVos wanting to debate me
put up yet what
this
ohos is calling in at the moment he's
ready to uh debate me uh he's calling in
now Dan do we have
him he's calling in now with peace and
love everybody please give it up for
[Applause]
VOS
uh standing by standing by I haven't
seen someone this obsessed with horses
since uh our buddy
keemstar yeah his his whole
Meme and his was even weirder and that
was [__]
[Music]
up well he yeah this this whole like the
ELA is a horse thing which a disgusting
lonely
[__] Loveless man who's dating a
20-year-old has the balls to insult
anybody a dude who's so hideous he
covers a he wears a hat in the bathtub
and the pool to cover his bald
glistening Dome as the balls to
criticize do your research Ethan when he
when he went off iner um Buffalo weapon
Buffalo we yeah tears of
joy Tacoma wept Buffalo High wept
are we waiting for something Dan no I
was up I wasn't really ready when you
set it up so a little so what do you
want me to do open it again well you
could just pretend like um like none of
that happened we going be like okay I'm
just staring at the TV oh hey uh we
actually have V on the line right now
hey on the line right now let me let me
bring him in on the call here
okay it's a lot of Hub it's a lot of Hub
up for not a lot
yeah well I was trying to just inter AC
it and then do it later once it was
ready but then but then you set it up so
then I was rushing and you're doing
great sweetie yeah I didn't what is this
what is this one a this sounds
interesting so this is what happened
about 45 minutes ago when he was talking
about it this is hot off the press by
the way Taylor fans there's no way we're
getting to Taylor do we got to put we're
not even we didn't get to we didn't get
to any of them it's just
the I knew no but it's so much fun I
know I just knew when we got on this we
weren't going to get off it so we've
been talking about vaj for and one and a
half hour so God we should we call it
vosch did what to what yeah what can we
call it where people Vos leaked his
horse
folder that's let me watch this let me
watch this joke a Twitter account named
Hitler CUNY 1488 sourced all the images
and said one of them was LLY I feel like
that's probably the character of the uh
the engagement that I'll see okay we
I've seen the images [__] don't
try to
don't not kidding okay so the the IM
that were in the the folder first of all
I'm the funniest things there by far to
be clear is that I think two of the
images that showed were literally just
nonp pornographic like Canon
images okay and the others there must be
the the Zelda photos yeah must be
talking about so is he saying Ru Ru
wasn't porn according to I don't know
what other ones because everything else
was very graic okay maybe he's gonna do
the argument where oh these characters
are actually thousand years old I'm not
you know that's not weird let's see I I
don't know where he's how is he going to
defend this from from tears of the
Kingdom like just standing Karu so that
was funny I did I you know that dude it
was like two of like 20 images bro the
fact that you're even taking it asde to
explain that is just guilt [__] guilt
guilt guilt yeah I also jerk off to that
too
man nothing wrong with it he's right
certainly
it wasn't even the porn of him it was
just it was just him standing there
still odd you're why are you downloading
pictures of king
araru I mean who knows maybe for a meme
or something you go from horse you go
from horse porn to kingar again let's
remember that that folder was the to be
organized that's what I'm saying he did
seemed like it was kind of a grab tempor
well well if they're organized by date
downloaded which is a common way to
organize uhhuh right and then these
would be temporarily related perhaps
yeah that's a okay that's a good point
we need to know how this document was
organized or is it categorized by most
used ah he's opened King raru thousand
times that's his go-to man that's his
closer he's beautiful so that fits um
and then you know again embarrassing
with the AI I know next time this
happens I'll make sure that it's like
real drawings of horse stick and not AI
C I apologize bro I saw that [__] it was
vile
you downloaded it so is he meing that
like his community is more upset about
the fact that it was AI art than the
fact that it was I guess was it like AI
art to me I don't know but who cares you
went you went to an image gener and said
you said what did you type to get that
you have to type something like young
girl to get that image I feel like yikes
well I mean the character alone like we
said 16 so and she's an old six or young
16 I'll be you know [__] me um
I assume they were pornographic no no no
those were those were like Nintendo
produced Canon images of R I'm pretty
sure like they were just oh my God the
mount you're focusing on rarus okay what
about this is so funny there's two
images and then there's that's not
pornographic maybe he saved them just
unrelated and then there's 20 completely
raw dog naked [__] porn where cartoon
mind you all right uh still of like
young girls what what's Ethan Sor Ethan
Sor in chat coping hard finally goodbye
Ethan sores who is that uh I guess they
were spamming about how you're you're a
coward and talk to vosch or whatever so
wait I banned them wait Ethan that must
be their username oh they just someone
I'm not I I'm the one that said all Deb
him man you know what I mean
supposedly he's talking about you and
his Discord and that's probably why
people are coming over fine you know we
love that about
you uh oh here this is this is from
right now yeah now this was posted on
Reddit and then uh so I can't confirm it
I'm not in his Discord but he says and
failed attempts to engagement just make
me look defensive I really doubt that's
a viable Avenue of Engagement I reach
out if I could people really really do
hate me I don't fall him for covering
drama but doing this gigantic generic
smear piece without reaching out bro are
talking beforehand I'm not even on
Twitter and barely talk to at all man yo
bro I yo I got to talk to you about this
horse porn [__]
brother I don't have that nature I don't
have that relationship with you how many
times that we
talked um he says it's a really it feels
at least a little shitty of him I mean
he's not being that harsh and I
understand that it would make him feel
shitty I've generally been pretty fair
to Ethan that's got okay man like again
I'm not
not
gonna what I just confirmed this is
legit my illustrations first appearance
on the illustrious if he want wait was
he on before no he's saying this is my
first appear but Vos I said I'll talk to
you I said I'll talk to
you should I let him call in now no we
got to go we're already it's almost F DM
the the podcast Instagram and we will
schedule something okay we we'll talk I
mean I'll give you the chance to um
defend yourself but you should know that
he did say in the beginning that he
watches your content and I like his
content I thought he was a talented
content creator
MH but you know Michael Jackson was a
talented singer no I'm kid I mean that's
too much that's that's too much he said
he didn't do anything like that that's
that's that's a poor joke he didn't do
anything like that he he didn't harm
anybody frankly right he just has some
weird opinions and looks at weird he
didn't harm anyone for the record he
said it's very disheartening I thought I
had something of a friend in
Ethan that's a new
message based on
what there's nobody in the world can you
make us a super cut please of the Vos
Ethan
friendship uh yes Don I just put in chat
I was going to build a bridge we were
just about to build a bridge let me let
me set that up let me get that ready
here bro what is being friend oh wait
wait wait wait new message why is Dan
pretending not to know me ooh
scorned xlover Dan why is Dan pretending
not to know me Dan wept Dan we what are
you talking about all I see is black on
I think he means just from
a being
a you don't know his content maybe wait
that's a wait I thought you were meing
he actually said that yeah I can send
you he says why does Dan pretend not to
know me and apparently were I know of
you I know you as the Tacoma WEP guy you
spend any time in Tacoma D Vos the look
in my opinion best way to handle yeah no
of course I know who he is I've just
I've never watched his content regularly
I'm not a fan like that that's all I
said Vos the best way to handle this is
like in my opinion let's just let's just
be like you know what Ethan you just
typed in the thing it's just black cam
sent the image it's just black right
that's the joke what did what was the
joke I didn't hear the joke I asked cam
for a super cut of you and your Rel
relationship cool I got it I just
dropped didn't get it at first there
here's the super gut thank you you're
still five for
five but Vos here's the thing let's just
own it and say you know
[Music]
what you know what I understand why it
came off that way yes I I do have a zoo
file thing but
like I've never T I've never done it to
an animal is that good or no probably
don't even that's probably probably just
about
it probably just lie about
it what does he do what should L
do um I think for start okay you know
what I would say if we if we uh if we
listen to his fans and his supporters
that have been yelling that this is bad
faith and taking him out of context or
whatever and we just presume that this
was purely just you know badly worded
stuff at the very least can we stop
talking about Horse let's make that
agreement put not talk about it that's a
good start right this that's an offer of
good faith let's cut out the CP
justification let's stop Philz about CP
find another example yeah right let's
let's let's put that chapter of
philosophy let's close the book on that
one and put it in a Dusty uh dark uh uh
shelf we don't want anyone to read that
one to be sorted yeah to be sorted later
I'm not into book burning but like the
last scene in Raiders of the Lost Arc so
like put it one of those boxes 100% of
all his other CP takes yeah endless rows
of no so let's put those in a box and
put them away with the horsecock stuff
let's start from there let's start there
I think Teddy says this is just a Witch
Hunt I'm disgusted we all at one point
watch horse related porn and yes some
reason BOS is the bad guy give me a
break everyone has watched horse porn if
you tell me you didn't I won't believe
you stop this Witch Hunt damn Teddy
earning the witch he just exposed the
whole chat I was afraid [__]
Hypocrites I was afraid for a minute
that you were for real but I'm I'm glad
that we took a journey together Dasha
says I love this community most of y'all
yeah thank you Dasha thank you so
much wow that was I mean I knew this was
going to be a journey BOS you can't be
mad that I did it's so funny like I've
never seen another Creator show their
their folder and it be
horses this is the first time this is a
novel and for it to again which only
realized in retrospect that there is
this horse meme around him existing for
years and this hisory such to like gift
to Comedy like Vos I have seen these
clips I've seen some of these clips
right floating around and and all his
fans are always like hoarding around him
like it's out of context blah blah blah
he explained it so it's easy to not
think about it too much but like when
you really dig into it bro it doesn't
get
better and also horsecock man I mean
come on dude we got to draw the
line you know
[__] so let's start with putting it in a
box and then what how does he say yeah
guys listen I'm a sexual deviant I have
issues I'm going to try to fix it that'd
be that'd be the best because listen I
got issues you know I'm G see a
therapist I'm G get off the horse and L
these stuff
sometimes
combined move back to Coma maybe get
back on Tinder man people love
[Music]
you and have some sympathy man they're
crying over
there yeah bro just just you know I
think that's good just
listen but if you're going to want to
argue with me about what you said isn't
[__] up that's not a conversation I
think is going to go great for you but
I'm H I guess I'll have it
if everyone is on board if people are
uncomfortable then I won't have it
mhm we probably be good
content one would argue great
[Music]
content he's such a good debater though
maybe he'll out debate me on this that
would be epic that would be crazy the
first
time damn I guess maybe you're making
sense maybey is good in some cases you
end up apologizing
look here's another one you know what
horses do have really big
[__] here's another one in the chat I'm
going to have to respectfully ask people
to stop saying this as a fan of both of
you the porn leaks are funny or
hilarious but it's the bad faith and
cutting of clips that is
disheartening we went through we
understand the point he was making must
did not do that we watch the whole thing
it's just that point also sucks here
here's the here's where the thing is if
you left that comment you are part of
this weird cult because you must not
have watched our thing and you've been
running defense for this guy for years
going anytime someone talks about this
and saying oh you cut it out of context
but here we very deliberately and
intentionally and in great detail and
effort and time looked at all the Clips
in their full context to get ahead of
this very expected response and we
understood the point that he was trying
to make it still didn't make it any
better no it did not it did not it you
have tried to get my [__] [__] for
years says his says that's what Mr Ed
said when he could finally talk I
was so what do we okay we got to change
the title what do we think I got to go
to the bathroom so bad go ahead let's
change it to a Tacoma this one's for you
shout out Tacoma County just call it
Tacoma we G need a ducky camera cute guy
so sweet somebody donated $10 said he
was just looking for a stable
relationship [__] got him nice dude
nice so Taylor Swift's out James Charles
is out bivo is out yeah sorry did we
talked about ccav in the beginning but I
mean that's not good for title though so
so do people care about the Vos thing is
that a title worthy I mean half of our
audience didn't even know who he was
when we started talking about I didn't
know who he was know about the bll and
the horse meet I was going to say the
bow the horse and the Wardrobe or
something like that an artistic title
today that's a really weird cryptic
title it's funny though had a DUI in
2005 oh my god of course earthquake oh
yeah earthquake happened that's the best
ever we had a natural disas we
experienced a natural disaster
earthquake slams The Studio live dur Rec
earthqu going for think you think that's
a good title yeah yeah I do let's do a
poll let's do a poll we haven't done
this in a while which the question is
this which one of these titles are you
going to be clicking on title which one
do you think is more clickable which
title are you clicking okay earthquake
earthquake vosch
Vos and then we don't even have to title
it vosch specific too it could be big
political streamers porn leaked true we
can't type we have to think of a way to
type it in that in that same I'm done
talking to this leftist
streamer I'm out I'm out on leftist
politics yeah oh that's good yeah that's
good why I'm leaving leftist politics
that's not that good no if people assume
smells his finger someone said if people
assume it's about Hassan too exactly
that's a good yeah that's what I'm
saying I'm no longer talking to him
I did joke about H I wonder if we can be
like this left this leftist streamer
went way too far Hassan H's people with
you can't say
Hy no H's people that's not you said
yourself they don't like each other
they're both socialists I mean that's
not how that works I they going run a
country together if they can't even look
at horn
together someone said V called horsing
around that's
okay that's good so earthquake vouch and
then H
clickbait Hanan
clickbait you can't put in H's name
that's too far got I think we can find a
way cuz it's clickbait h [__] a horse
100% proof Hassan copy Hassan copy uh
something maybe um nerd Angel says if
you don't let vosch on to let you know
he wants to be the horse you hate
content that's true it's for the I mean
for the content it seems like it'd be
good somebody said horse
Quake why socialism is
bad that's funny I'm going to go run to
the bathroom so whatever you guys are
saying now I'll just say it in a couple
minutes beautiful nice you guys got to
show this picture of um duck
duck this it's five we got to go we did
a title up in this I was trying to say
vote you said
like if you were serious I haven't put
up the poll yet cuz I wasn't sure if you
were Ser we have B earthquake Ving
around I need thex wi or or or or some
what is a wild clickbate we could say
the most shocking content we've seen in
years I think that's the winner right
there it's not even a lie frankly yeah
but it's very like click baity and
generic streamer leak the most shocking
leak we've seen I like the word click
the mouse leak is good the what do you
like the word leak is I'm saying Okay so
let's do go with like shocking leak
clickbait not even clickbait that ain't
some clickbait Sensational but it's not
really hor the mouse horse gasm they
they said that in in that one video we
reacted to a long time ago he called it
a horse gasm wow Mar gasm oh
margas yeah just just poed up in my head
no bucket is Reed oh wow the earthquake
is the earthquake is
winning really yeah it's pretty good
it's a good idea it's very unlikely to
catch a big earth earthquake they lose
power no it's like it also makes it very
specific to this app if it's like wow
some extraneous forces really really
uh maybe we can oh [__] hold on the the
clickbait ones take is like close to
overtaking it oh oh oh true we sur40
right now we survived
2924 foret we we survived 911 minus dude
imagine massive not September we got
that backwards massive earthquake hits
the studio live mhm so let's do a combo
let's
say um gone beastiality gone and horse
pork earthquake live on stream someone
said porn leak so devastating it caused
an
earthquake this leak ruined the
streamer's career might well
do well seems like it it's already been
out forever and nobody cares like those
other T this is crazy
caming I like
it
oh I [__] Ste
biscuit I just learned an interesting
fact biscuit Miranda Sings is from
Tacoma Washington yes she is she's
weeping she's weet oh my God
F earthquake hits the studio
live or any other verbiage you guys like
yeah I think that's clean M that's clean
to the point you know so earthquake hits
Studio live okay yeah
comma Earth do it live Quake hits the
studio live comma and then uh shocking
leak the most shocking leak we've seen
the most shocking leak we've seen in
years yeah it's pretty good mhm and then
maybe in parenthesis Vos so like maybe
some people know Fe featuring we'll have
him in the
thumbnail feature I don't we'll have him
in the thumbnail yeah okay yeah thumb so
read it earthquake hits the studio live
and the most shocking leak we've seen in
years okay let's do it live so I guess
cam will need a new thumb and uh let's
throw it up so there we go thank you
everybody and what a terrific episode
we've had here today and a great week of
shows has it not been yeah thank you to
everybody being it up give it up
everybody um so thanks for watching
Everybody thanks for uh thank you to all
of our fans thank you to all our
supporters you guys make the absolute
world I talked about it on members
yesterday but I was saying thanks to the
members I don't have to even consider
firing AB because we don't have sponsors
we don't have sponsors and because of
our members I don't have to weigh in my
mind every week does love have to go
back to Sweden does AB have to go back
to Detroit uhhuh and uh who else can I
send somewhere and I'm sending Dan to
Iceland for no reason I would send Dan
to Tacoma I'm sending Dan Tacoma to we
to go horseback we don't have to worry
about that we don't have to worry about
any of that because you guys support us
and we're so grateful for that so thank
you and thank you to
um thank you to peanut butter and F 50
gifted oh wow generous thank you cool
and and be um be on the
ready I don't know what I'm trying to
say but be on the lookout Monday morning
for the teddy fresh free shipping guys
and free shipping free shipping y'all us
domestic us yeah uh free shipping though
for us domestic so take advantage
enjoy and um also I will say this I'm
kidding both ab and love are tremendous
emplo I would I would I couldn't you
couldn't pay me to to separate it's my
favorite joke honestly I love I love
it are you kidding no I I I love that
one imagine one day I have no money to
pay my bills and have to move back to
coold Detroit and well it makes you
appreciate what you have yeah yeah yeah
when I left Detroit we so you can stay
if you want if if I'm out I gotta go
back in Mya you got nice AB I don't
control where you live do you know how
much you know how much my rent is you
you do do you know how much my rent is
here or there here how much you want to
say more more I'll say it you're saying
you wouldn't be able to afford it it if
you have a job no money so what's your
rent 4,200 wa dude what you paying you
guys are paying that a lot no wait what
the [__] they have a really nice place
that's a lot I know you guys got you
guys upgraded I didn't realize it was
like a [__] monster well our our
studio was three
grand really you guys have been out of
the rental game for a while so I'm
paying for downtown which I've always
mhm which is downtown is kind of a
Bizarro I know nice not nice it's
probably but I live in the nin part so
I'm surprised no wait I listen I know I
haven't rented in a while but I feel
like I'm not that out you know that's
what I thought it's Skyrocket last few
years we looked around we looked around
and and anything that had two bedrooms
was like 4,000 or 3900 was the cheapest
dude that's [__] yeah I have a
two-bedroom and mine is not that much
cheaper than that I think it's probably
only cheaper cuz I've been there for a
few years so what are you paying can I
ask you don't have to say uh after all
the fees and [__] that always get
stacked on it's like 307
[Music]
yeah that's a big difference that's like
$600 difference I mean that's a lot is
it yeah I mean yeah but that's that's
really expensive May's place is very
nice though say
congrats no someone says Ethan realizing
he us to pay his crew more don't worry
about
them I mean we can everyone's Tak we're
good I mean that that he has every right
to complain about it being expensive I
just moved into a new apartment it's
beautiful and I'm loving it y how much
is it but the teddy fresh throw it fits
my living room so we love it girl I love
it you know how much were were paying in
Michigan for a three floor
house how much 1,400 a mon is that
before you came here yeah so it wasn't
that long ago yeah and it's a fle how
many square foot Lena do you know it's
it's like the nicest area in our on our
area like we could walk everywhere yeah
la is too [__] expensive dud it is it
sucks dude
the city is just a disaster like
um the zoning laws are just so messed up
they're so little inventory and so high
demand I don't understand the logic of
the people that run the city 1,400
square feet well I don't think it's the
1400 yeah well you know what never mind
it's 515 we don't need to get into
zoning wall right now well what's your
take on the zoning law issues that's
plaguing all right thank you everyone we
had a lot of fun here today
congratulations on the beautiful
apartment though you guys I'm happy for
you thank you thank you and you too
Olivia yeah and love and love is also
relatively new in your apartment
everybody's we're all living
maybe but it's a great place to live M
isn't it love it I do love La you like
it love how you liking La yeah I'm
enjoying it good a huge change for you
Al you were here for a long time you
know I I got a nice and I'm really
comfortable in there a and I live close
to the studio 10 minutes so [__] less
than 10 minutes good yeah it's good I
have a very comfortable day today that's
that's good I [__] hate the city I
[__] hate the city dude really [__]
la oh no you really hate it you came
here from Atlanta right well no that's
Sam I used to live in Atlanta he live in
Atlanta as well oh oh right right right
about that where did you live came from
Boston I came from Boston yeah Bost boy
what what can we do for you so that
you're you know what I mean it's I just
keep you know thank you you guys make it
worth it I hate the city I love the
people here in this room there you
go all right listen we do have to go
it's getting so damn late thank you
everyone thank you thank you thank you
thank you with peace and love have a
great weekend and we will be back on
Monday for another fantastic week of
shows you know it see you next
time